[Laughter]
hey everybody it's friday night april
tom's day
[Laughter]
i totally forgot his april 1st today
well because i said to him i was setting
up the i was set with the broadcast and
i was like what should we what should we
name this and he immediately said april
times day yeah and i was like okay being
a fool
yeah
oh [ __ ] you should have worn like a
jester hat i don't have one we don't
have a jester huh i used to have a
jester how where the [ __ ] did that go
i bought it at disney like a million
years ago
but i don't know what happened to it it
was red and purple and shiny so who we
got here they're just all showing up now
oracle's there oscar's in there ian's in
there sabrina hugo
tammy's in there yep everybody yeah hey
tammy i ate the last of those white
chocolate truffles today i eat only one
of the uh well the chunkies are big
chunkies yeah the chocolate still got
that cookie butter right there we were
thinking about what that would be good
on is it just good on your toast or is
it or do you maybe like animal crackers
or those yeah i mean toast
because well people will put people put
like [ __ ] nutella on toast probably
pretty good
oh yeah yeah oh that's a good idea
probably yeah like animal crackers yeah
animal crackers
yeah i feel like something like a like a
cookie that isn't like super super sweet
yeah that is like kind of buttery flavor
like butter cookies or something or it
might be good it's you know what it
might be good on just like plain fries
like saltines might be good on sliced
apples
oh yeah well i think tammy even said
that oh yeah that it was gonna like
pieces of banana and like apples and
stuff probably yeah because honestly
like apples with like dipped in peanut
butter is delightful so i'm sure that's
probably just fattening well yeah but
you gotta have a treat sometime okay in
this cold horrible world
it's like hard to find happiness
yeah tammy said i eat it mainly on apple
slices or bananas yeah see so you're
getting fruit it's healthy god damn it
yeah graham's in gramps they're here
yeah they're all [ __ ] every time he
refers to himself in the third person
like it makes me laugh yes i need to
start doing that yeah no i don't
it probably wouldn't be as funny
okay guys so pop pop here just off today
with my four-year-old grandkid
fun fun fun but the house looks like a
bomb went off it's amazing how quickly a
child can just decimate yeah a [ __ ]
area well they just don't put anything
away
yeah they're just like it's almost kind
of like they come into a room just like
just toys phew yeah and there's legos
and [ __ ] all over the place yeah that's
just funny
so the
phantom of the opera show seems to be a
success everybody liked it
um we need you guys to come up with some
uh
some more subjects for us that are kind
of like rebecca had a great idea she
sent to me on and i put it in the poll
on patreon that went up this morning
she um on instagram she said oh you guys
should do like similar but do a show
about like the real stories behind like
grimm's fairy tales because some of
those were based on real things that
happened as well like you know what i
mean i don't know so uh i didn't know
that they were yeah well some of them
were like obviously they didn't like you
know there's not witches and stuff but
you know some of them are kind of based
on real things billy goats gruff is you
know don't talk to them bums sleep
underneath the damn bridges
[ __ ] like that you know what i mean
old ladies might eat you crazy old
ladies might i mean they might you don't
know yeah they're probably if they were
hungry enough probably a lot of
cannibalism
back in the middle ages man gotta watch
those old days people were poor you know
in certain areas they're like wow that
baby looks so succulent yeah
we started already no need for me too
said i just finished watching red letter
media cover dark man yeah it's weird
because i think like a day or two after
we put our thing of dark man up they put
theirs up because i watched it earlier
today too
um a lot of the same kind of stuff like
they're both really fans of that movie i
just thought it was funny i said well
maybe it's just that a lot of people are
doing it because uh because shutter just
added right i feel like yeah people are
people review the free [ __ ]
yeah i mean well that's the thing if you
already have i mean we have
several streaming services we have
shutter we have hulu we have amazon
prime and then there's free ones like 2b
and pluto and stuff like that there's
you know and there's a bunch of [ __ ] on
youtube too that you can watch for free
so it's like we'll pay for a movie if
you know we want to see it bad enough
yeah like i don't mind renting something
for you know 3.99 or whatever
but
most of the time we're gonna err on the
side of
let's uh let's find something that's
free
well it's not free since we're already
paying for it but we're talking about
bluebird was probably uh you know ooh
that's a good idea too i'm going to put
that in the next
yeah yeah cause i see i wrote down
brother's grim here but yeah there's
stuff behind that you know warning women
about predatory men i mean that was way
up into the 1800s you had guys
who would marry women one after another
[ __ ] take out life insurance policies
kill them move on to the next town like
serial killers
that dude's doing it
yeah we're not doing it to [ __ ]
worthless women either you know young
good-looking beautiful women one that
you would keep it's not like you're
doing it to
you know not like this once you just
kill and throw in a dumpster yeah
high-value women
well no
you know what i'm talking about i mean i
know what you mean i was talking about
the way you phrased it yeah no exactly
what i'm talking about
it's not like it's not like it's not
like well okay they had a whole guy they
had guys that were doing that to old
hags
yeah you know
for a whole living
you know [ __ ] seducing old hags that
had a lot of money
you get them to sign over there [ __ ]
then you kill them
they had guys that did that did that i
mean [ __ ] like that was shockingly
common yeah back in the old days yep uh
and there was a small percentage of
women doing that [ __ ] too right yeah i
mean not
obviously not as large as the dudes
doing it but yeah there were some women
doing it was easier for a guy to get
away with it because he he could travel
more openly and [ __ ] go from one
place to another open up a new life and
a new identity
because it's common for a single guy to
be traveling around not so much a single
woman yeah not in those days no
yes it was harder to like keep a liberal
yeah they had to stay in one area well
real quick they'd go in hold on
80 your husband's died
that seems a little fishy within a few
months of you marrying them and you had
insurance policies for each one of them
yeah
because they had women that would do
that
well i started [ __ ] psychos it was
like much housing by proxy
yeah well i told i told you guys um
before i think i mentioned this before
but i had been watching the show it's on
two i've watched them all now because
there's like 50 something episodes on
there of a show called bizarre murders
it was on to be
and i don't know where like what channel
it came from originally
but there was one case on there that
really made an impression because it was
these two old ladies
that were in like a really nice like
swanky rest home in i think it was in
florida
and their whole shtick was that they
volunteered at a homeless shelter
at a place where homeless people go to
get food like they you know go cook and
serve people
and they would find a homeless guy
that they thought um
didn't have anyone in the area
and they would be like oh we think
you're so talented and awesome look we
have this apartment you can live in and
we'll give you like a monthly stipend or
whatever and they're like all you have
to do is just sign this little piece of
paper right here and they were like okay
whatever and then they would run them
over with a car yeah
so it looked like an accident right
and uh yeah like two nice little
and they weren't poor they weren't i
mean because they
i think this the the reason they started
doing that was because they were in this
really really nice rest home and they
were like well i guess their savings
were running out yeah and they were like
well we're gonna have to go to like some
[ __ ] ratchet like you know what i
mean like right now somebody to die so
we need to like kill off a bomb yeah uh
and you know take out insurance on them
but that's the thing it's like
i don't know but i mean they they only
did it once well did they do it once or
twice i think they might have done it
one time and nobody because who's gonna
suspect two little old ladies nobody i
remember that story vaguely
the one about the guy who was killing
all the young wives
and he was supposed to be like
an okay looking dude you know he wasn't
anything great but he was
he was marrying like little hotties
and he stayed married to him for a few
months take out a life insurance
policy on them and while they were in
the bathtub he'd go in there and grab
their feet and pull their feet up like
that and i'm like how the hell do you
drown somebody in a foot of water well
you can drown in the pile of desserts
yeah because she's already bent up so
she can't get her head out of the water
and he'd drown him like that and then
reposition them and [ __ ] make it look
like they got man they must have just
fallen asleep in the tub i think he made
it look like they were getting drunk and
falling asleep and drowning themselves
in the tub or put logan or something
wasn't it
he he gave some kind of plausible
explanation of what had happened
but he'd then he'd collect his reward
and then he'd
sell everything off and move yeah
do it again and do it again in another
state yikes
and uh
i think that particular guy they think
they tracked down i think didn't he put
some pinkertons on him
to try to figure out maybe i have to
remember because the thing about it is
that
you know uh the details are saying there
was more than one that did something
like that so i'm it's hard for me to
like come up with there was like a
couple that like poisoned a bunch of
[ __ ] too yeah like thomas neil
cream and those kind of people yeah that
they thought was maybe jack the ripper
if i remember correctly
from memory if memory serves i think
that i think that they pretty much
nailed it down that killed that dude
killed at least 12 people doing that
all of them women
pretty young women we're talking early
20s which is crazy yeah that's crazy why
not just settle down and [ __ ] have a
normal family life with some you know
because well he he there had been more
to it he must have been a serial killer
literally yeah you know the dumb thing
about that and i kind of feel like
see this is what yeah i think that the
reason that they keep doing it is
because it's not just because they need
the money or [ __ ] like that but you want
to kill him right they just like want to
kill him because you would think and
don't take this the wrong way but you
would think that if you were gonna do it
look i'm gonna take the plunge i really
need a lot of money i'm gonna like marry
somebody take out a insurance policy and
then i'm gonna bump them off right um
and then i'll have a nest egg yeah you
would think that if you had a big enough
life insurance policy a couple million
like you wouldn't have to do it again
you're like okay that's it one and done
money couldn't have been the motive so i
kind of feel like even though money was
even either that or they had some other
things like a gambling addiction or some
other [ __ ] like that where they just
kept blowing [ __ ] money you know what
i'm saying thank you very much trey
awesome just showing up
right out the gate yep hey guys there's
something going on with patreon it won't
let me back into my account huh i'll
have to check on that later or in the
morning when i'm not the hungover or
whatever or i'm not drunk or whatever
um
but anyway hopefully we didn't get
kicked off patreon no we're still there
i just i was just on there today okay
because i was like [ __ ] with the
yeah i was just i was just [ __ ] with
the polls because our poll went up this
morning but i changed a couple of the
topics because somebody gave me some
good ideas like i said like the room
like the fairy tales one uh gregor says
discussion night who is the worst person
you ever met
uh that was one question two how to make
your woman listen and obey
what
grant is asking questions that's a good
question
oh man the worst person you ever met oh
my god there's a lot of competition in
that area
who was the worst person i ever met
um
now i'm not really sure if did i ever
meet anybody i mean i've met some people
that maybe were like serial killers that
i didn't know about god damn
uh i'm trying to think of like who the
worst person i'd have to say peter
murphy
worst impression of ever ever
really from that dude that's an
instantly that didn't even enter my mind
just because i wasn't thinking of
celebrities i was thinking of like
people i'd worked with or oh oh i know
who yeah i know who yeah they did you
worked with yeah yeah i'm not going to
say like what it is or where it is or
anything like that because he's still
around and he doesn't live that far from
here
um but yeah
he was
and like i said i could i'll probably
think of somebody even worse than that
but
yeah that dude was uh something else
he didn't really he didn't do anything
to me personally because he was
terrified of me
um but
i don't know why
but uh yeah he sucked
he sucked a lot
how to make a woman listen and obey
we listen we just don't want to do what
you guys say if it matters to you you're
already a beta
you shouldn't care if she's listening or
a vague you should you should be doing
your own thing okay
uh she should you know who cares if
she's not listening and obeying
[Laughter]
what does what does that matter
yeah
that's yeah i'm kind of like yeah if you
care about it then then you've already
lost it you've already lost yeah because
you know if if you want somebody to take
it you just leave well the thing about
it do people still have the obey thing
in their wedding vows i'm sure some
people do i'm never worried about it
that seems so
archaic
that just brilliantly that was our see
that was back that was back in the old
days when like [ __ ] you better do what
i tell you well that was back in the day
where [ __ ] she may have not have been
a willing bride
that i think that's you know
pawned off kind of sold off you know for
the dowry by her parents type of deal or
a shotgun wedding so yeah
she's pregnant
[ __ ] he better obey
[Laughter]
women didn't make money back then either
well they weren't allowed to
yeah somewhere i mean i i'm not too so
sure about that because men i read all
books and they were
working on farms and going to the market
well that kind of stuff made money but
they weren't they were closed out of a
lot of i don't think they could i don't
think they could
make a whole bunch of money no they
probably would
had restrictions about whether or not
they could do banking transactions and
things like that well do you know
that may have been by state even in the
united states as far as i know in all
the states please correct me if i'm
wrong but a woman could not uh or as far
as i know i don't know if it was just a
single woman or a married woman you
could not open a credit card in your
name alone or a checking account until
the early 1970s yeah um
you know you could have one if your
husband was also if it was like a joint
account but you couldn't open one by
yourself yeah that's kind of some
archaic [ __ ] even back in the 70s well
yeah that's what i was shocked yeah i
think it was 1974 they overturned that
that must have been
holdovers from
the very late 1800s 1900s probably just
mostly at the state level
because i think a lot of those laws had
to do with um
preventing runaway brides and runaway
daughters i think that's what that and
keeping your daughter from eloping and
that kind of [ __ ] or maybe they should
look into why those women were running
away in the first place maybe they had
good cause [ __ ] are crazy
you know how we do
we're all crazy
she won't listen
like i said we do listen we just think
y'all are full of [ __ ]
[Music]
there's another time
you know um
and like i said this all it all is going
to depend on the state
and another thing is [ __ ] your ethnic
background's gonna gonna uh
gonna matter
a white woman was not very free she was
worth money
literally
so she was not kind of like especially
if she was from a rich family
so her dad kind of had custody of her
her whole purpose really ultimately was
to be married off to some other rich
dude
well that's why there's a bunch of money
that's why they're still like i said i
don't know if they still do it in
weddings nowadays but they still they
obey [ __ ] and the vows and that was why
your dad
gave you away yeah because you had to be
like under a man's protection and that
were we're passing you on to another man
there bye yeah some poor chick and a
dumbbell tenement in [ __ ] 1800's well
yeah they didn't worry about it damn
[ __ ] some this i mean you had to work
louisiana sharecropper girl everybody
had to work the kids had to work or
they'd all starve yeah white or black
they didn't matter they really they
really didn't matter they weren't worth
much
you know to the families that that they
were
part of
they might have been
almost kind of a little bit more like a
hungry mouth to feed half the time so
nobody really cared what where they went
or if they ran off
you know and
if you were kind of like of that class
you were never really going to have
enough money at one time to even worry
about a bank account they kept cash in
the house
you know nobody wouldn't have been much
at one time yeah that's what i'm saying
they probably didn't even have the money
to open it right it was probably just
like as soon as we get money we gotta
spend it on [ __ ] we had to pay rent or
we gotta pay for food yeah whatever
banks were only for rich people yeah
normal people didn't didn't have
anything to do with banks
so
the whole thing about women not being
able to have banking accounts and credit
cards that really probably didn't become
an issue for ninety percent of women
until till the moderate era
yeah because they weren't well until
after the second world war i would think
right because yeah although maybe before
maybe before because uh there were
single women running around new york you
know [ __ ]
finally dressed and living in apartments
and living by themselves and talking on
telephone and you know what i mean so it
was kind of scandalous back then yeah
but they had women that were totally
modern living like a modern person
of today back in the 20s yeah
you know um but like i said it was only
a big city it's kind of scandalous kind
of yeah but there was nothing anybody
can do about it they did it anyway
that's right [ __ ] just look at mate
west yeah mae west was like that yeah
and she
did [ __ ] that was just scandalous for
the arrow like she had black boyfriends
she was like [ __ ] all y'all she liked
big black dudes you know and [ __ ]
everybody knew
and and they would like comments say
you had to read it between the lines you
know the newspapers you know
you know she showed up with her big
strong strapping handsome
black bodyguard again you know what i
mean [ __ ] yeah bodyguard yeah
she's like oh he guards my body out
like a chauffeur
i mean
she he was the show he drove around yeah
you know may west was the [ __ ] mae west
was the [ __ ]
everybody knew
we should do a show about mayweather
well actually one of the i think one of
the um
wait did i leave it in there or did i
take it out one of the things in the
patreon poll that i was i wanted to do
like more tales of old hollywood because
remember we did that one before and we
talked about like small boots we talked
about like fatty arbuckle and stuff like
that and i kind of wanted to do another
one like that with like more
with other stories because i know there
are a lot of uh we could talk about her
on that if that whatever one
gram there's also says more topics
working at disney good paying jobs are
hot and boring under that mickey mouse
costume terrible jobs we know people who
work there yeah
it depends on what you do there yeah um
the more glamorous it is the worse the
job is yeah i kind of feel like they
don't the pay isn't
great yeah i mean in florida the wages
are pretty low
um
for just across the board
and um you know cost of living is lower
too a bit but
i mean [ __ ] i was a you know i was a
graphic designer with you know 10 20
years experience
and no job would offer me more than like
15 an hour you know what i mean whereas
in a big city i'd be making many times
that
so
there's that but like so disney doesn't
pay that great they don't
as far as i know like because we know a
lot of people that worked there in
varying uh you know positions yeah they
don't really treat their employees all
that well from what we've heard yep
and we can we can say talk about it now
because most of them won't work there
again they don't work there anymore most
of them
um i did i dated one of the sleeping
beauties jenny couldn't stand or jenny
hated her she was [ __ ] kind of
annoying but yeah she was very annoying
anyway i mean i wasn't just being an
[ __ ] she was she was kind of annoying
but
it was fun anyway
she was just it was just like horror
stories you know from her
she was
good looking she looked like sleeping
beauty looked like a drawn disney disney
character
which might be kind of goofy looking but
she looked like one of them you see them
she could dance and she could sing she
would do the whole thing they used her
image and commercials corporate
commercials and stuff
don't pay them a dime
not a dime it's almost damn near minimum
wage job
thank you camp guy thank you thank you
very much something that she aspired to
be a waitress
because that's where you made real money
and i was just going like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with that place
and it's because they got
a lot of
suckers
that want to be in the limelight and
will take a job like that because they
think they'll get ahead
just to be
famous for a few years in the [ __ ] in
your mind in the park
but they're using you up the mechanics
are making much more money
yeah i really would not understand i
wouldn't go the performance route i mean
if you work behind the scenes like in a
technical then that's probably better
yeah
but um performers i feel like kind of
get [ __ ] [ __ ]
and especially if you work in the parks
as one of the costumed characters i
would absolutely not do that in any way
shape or form um not only is it
unbelievably hot in those things and
plus you have kids like kicking you in
the balls like pretty much all day
but and i don't know if this is true but
i've heard from multiple sources that
they make you share like undergarments
they only have like so many
undergarments and they only like wash
them like so many times like they go
under these costumes i don't know if
that's true or not but i've heard that
but the insides of the costumes
apparently
i think they have some kind of like air
conditioning mechanism but it doesn't
really work all that good and apparently
they smell really bad yeah
yeah there's a big rivalry between the
people who they got face versus fur
rivalry yeah the girls who and the
people that you can see their faces
those are kind of like the upper echelon
performers the people that are in those
furry costumes or the lower echelon
performers and there's like a rivalries
between them then there's all these
[ __ ] rules that you wouldn't think of
the the face girls and the
the uh
the princesses
a lot of them to really pay bills are
doing cam girl jobs
and who knows maybe
maybe escorting
because they don't pay them [ __ ]
yeah they really don't yeah and they
have expensive tastes in things
so
they had to have all these [ __ ] rules
like if the company caught you
performing as those characters in
into pornographic
roles and doing [ __ ] where that
minnie mouse is you can't wear it
if they ever [ __ ] catch you
being a disney princess and during a cam
girl session [ __ ] your ass is grass
they have to sue you and ever i mean
disney has all the money yeah so they
will just sue you
into a little bitty they will take all
your money and your house and your car
and your children because they had girls
who were those characters at the parks
and then bought their own costumes and
were [ __ ] making extra money on the
cabs and proving that they were [ __ ]
the real thing
showing their pictures from work make a
lot of money they got their [ __ ]
asses sued into oblivion i mean don't
ever get don't get on the wrong side of
disney because they are very very
litigious they will sue the [ __ ] out of
you yep
honestly they back i don't know if
they're if they still do this nowadays
but back in the old days you so much
just like painted donald duck on the
side of your daycare and they would
[ __ ] sue your ass thank camp guy
you know yeah i mean they're just just
kind of dicks like i said that's a while
back that they did that yeah but do you
remember it was like some dinky ass
rinky-dink daycare somewhere i don't
even remember where it was and they
painted some disney characters they just
had like a local artist come and paint
some disney characters on the side you
know what i mean it wasn't like a big
deal or anything
and uh disney found out about it and
sued them okay at which point hannah and
like
said that not anymore they fought that
and one i don't know what you're talking
about but the girls [ __ ] wearing
their costumes yeah i don't know if
that's referring to something i don't
know what he's talking about you have
that
okay
but um
yeah but yeah i was gonna say uh and
this was like years ago because i
remember reading about it but hannah
barbera i think it was hannah barbera
they were so like incensed by what
disney did that they stepped in and went
to the daycare and said you can paint
our characters on the side you should if
you want so they could paint like fred
floyd santa chess [ __ ] like that says
more topics one hot god chick sitting at
a bar do normally dudes have a chance of
getting some strange absolutely not no
absolutely not probably not who would
you rather party with gary newman or
trent resident newman newman big time
not i don't have to think about that i
ran into trent resner and um
and uh [ __ ] uh oh [ __ ] what's his
name
marilyn manson what's his real name
[ __ ]
brian yeah [ __ ] brian warner one of
our best friends is came up with brian
he's from here
and um
i ran into him in in the french quarter
trent rezner is not really a goth dude
when you see him he's going to be
[ __ ] wearing [ __ ] bermuda shorts
and a [ __ ]
tan tank top and [ __ ] does he have
[ __ ] crocs on he probably well it was
before crocs but he'd be yeah he'd be
wearing well now he'd probably flip
flops and [ __ ] but they're so
comfortable driving around and just
driving around in his [ __ ] used
[ __ ] ferrari
listening to his own albums
but uh
that's another story from so douchey i
think you've told that one before
like where he was outside the thing like
listening to his like the the stereo
came on and like his own head like a
hole was on
he was listening to his own [ __ ] in the
car
yeah that was that uh
that was down at the french quarter at
uh
the uh
the hellfire club
uh
and uh hellfire was uh
pierre's place and um
i think he might have another name for
no i think it was called hellfire
and uh but no there was uh several
people would blow in and out of there it
was a private club you know it wasn't
really open to the public
goss knew where it was he'd let you in
because technically it was his house but
it had a dance floor a dj
kind of like legalities that yeah it had
it had [ __ ] an upper loft with a
[ __ ] mattress up there it's where i
[ __ ] met my first wife [ __ ] he was
getting busy after that
yeah she's regular too and um
the uh
ran into people that you would like what
and they were really cool one was jerry
springer
jerry springer was up there and me and
him are watching the [ __ ] fetish show
and he was buying the drinks because you
guys are great man you guys are great
he's like that
but you think i just love it yeah jerry
jerry springer would go to the [ __ ]
uh
um back in those days would go to the
[ __ ] bourbon street all the time he
loved new orleans
and another one that we ran into showed
up and when i'm saying the club it's
pretty small you know what i mean if
there were 50 people in there it was
packed
uh mostly there would be like 20 people
in there everybody knew each other and
then it'd be like guests that shut
um gary oldman was in there
i didn't recognize him though
at first what like what year was this it
was
1998 maybe
98 about 98
maybe 99 98 around that time i'm trying
to think what he looked like in 1998
just looked like a dude
well i didn't expect him to look like a
[ __ ] he looked like commissioner
galapagos
in batman was commissioner gordon
okay you know what i'm out
things like that did he have like little
glasses and he kind of looked like yeah
i think he didn't have a mustache and
[ __ ] uh just uh jeans on and a
t-shirt just like a regular did he
didn't have like a hair butt like he did
in the no none of that vampire stuff
they just let him in because how funny
would that be if he wore the hair butt
wig they just let him in because they
knew because this gary [ __ ] old man
yeah yeah yeah what are you doing do you
tell him no yeah he let him run in
pierre let him right in
he was like
because you're gary [ __ ] you could
find out about the place over over over
the old internet that's usually how most
people [ __ ] found
found it
searching searching for a goth club in
the french quarter over the old internet
and uh it would you'd find because there
were lists remember there used to be
lists of goth clubs yeah in the old
internet and and you could show the
internet the international goth club
listing or something like that and it
was just like a black site with like red
links there was no public door went by
state and then country yeah
well you would just see the bottom of
the staircase with a light
and
bars
and a doorbell and if you ring the
doorbell a few minutes later [ __ ]
goth chicken big old big old [ __ ]
black dress and a [ __ ] veil look like
a [ __ ] morning vest morning dress
would come down and ask you what you
wanted and that was pierre's wife
she didn't know you she asked me what
you want she knew you should let you in
and then um she talked to a few few
minutes and if she liked you she'd let
you hit
but it was his house but it looked like
a club inside it was a club he was
selling liquor in there
well like i said if you name it
as a house party yeah and you can't get
away with you don't need a liquor
license right it was not open to the
company
he was not
actually selling
liquor
you were supposed to donate
yeah that's how you get it pay the bill
sure
pay the booze bill could you byob no no
no
but
money was never that's what probably
money was never discussed
really you know what i mean it's just
that every time i got a drink i'd
[ __ ] give him 10 bucks i didn't ask
for any change back it's usually how it
went
you know the bartender would just
take to take the rest
well that yeah that makes sense well
like i said you're not going to get into
you know
you can skirt the laws yeah as long as
you don't have i mean as long as you're
not breaking the fire codes there were
and there's open candles in there oh
[ __ ] okay it looked like something by
the damn interview with a vampire there
was [ __ ]
french there was that [ __ ] french
moss hanging [ __ ] well nowadays they
could have like the fake like
battery-powered game yeah so they're
probably oh they had real candles going
in certain little cul-de-sacs and stuff
and
weird like santeria [ __ ] shrine up in
the wall you know that kind of stuff
just that
neat [ __ ] like that neat [ __ ] yeah
and it had uh french
french doors that were like windows that
would open up you walk out to the outer
balconies
you know there's like a cross there's a
door and a window at the same time what
friends that's a friendship right yeah
they had those all throughout the out
were they stained glass no oh too bad
it was impossible to [ __ ]
it was hot in there it was impossible to
air condition it only one room was air
conditioned his bedroom and when people
were in there it was locked you couldn't
get in there
well yeah he didn't want people pawing
around his [ __ ] bedroom yeah
bob apple says we should do a show about
gigi allen
yeah
we probably should that might be a good
new guy named ty he was [ __ ] friends
with gg
up in boston yeah
yeah he said that gigi was was great
until he started getting attention by
[ __ ] being an [ __ ] and then he
would never yeah we were talking about
yeah he was mad at gigi he said gg he
was really good when he would actually
perform well like i said if it gets to a
point where he's like well [ __ ] why
should i like work and like
produce anything when everybody's just
gonna give me money for
pooping on my hands and like throwing it
at him yeah then [ __ ] that's much easier
jeffreys jeffrey sent us ten dollars
thank you jeffy art i live down in
wilton manors florida my rent is nearly
fifteen hundred dollars a month one
bedroom one bath which is considered
cheap for the area working three
part-time jobs just to make it and love
every minute of it mostly okay yeah i
mean
i'm not saying like florida's cheap but
it i mean the cost of living is
lower down here than other places
sometimes
our mortgage here is [ __ ] about two
grand a month man and it's two floors
with [ __ ] all this [ __ ] room in
here
owning a house is the way to go
apartments are not really the way to go
depending on where it's i don't know
where it is yeah i mean the thing about
it i owned a house before in daytona
and after that i kind of swore i would
never own one ever again because it was
a [ __ ] nightmare but the house that i
owned was old yeah so
every time something breaks hey there's
termites or hey there's this not the
other you have to pay for it it's not
like you can just call it the landlord
and have them fix it for you you know
what i mean
so
there was that
maniac i heard that i think i from what
i remember they told me he got killed in
prison he didn't get killed in prison
okay hey
that he died an ot in a hotel room yeah
the story i heard is that it was prison
now i don't think he was killed in
president okay yeah i thought he just
odd okay
d.j maynard says and jello b afro is not
gay he just pretends to be gay
i think maybe people think that because
of his voice
is that why i thought he said he was gay
no i never heard him say that i think
people i i think that maybe sometimes if
people have that perception of him it's
because of the way he talks like if that
he has like the quote-unquote gay voice
kind of i don't i guess i don't know i
can't really think of any other reason
why you would think that
somebody told me that
um
[Music]
victor says i have a little
three-bedroom new construction and my
mortgage is 1200
my one bedroom apartment was 1050. yeah
honestly um even in
uh central florida
you're not gonna get a decent
apartment for less than a thousand
dollars a month and actually
probably not for less than 1200 you can
get an apartment for that
but it's not gonna be in a good
neighborhood i'm gonna tell you that
right now jello may not have been or
excuse me uh gigi maybe he didn't die in
prison but i heard a [ __ ] compelling
[ __ ] tale
of how jim morrison really died
like these are some people that
were hanging out with him in that era
evidently and the story that they told
sounds a lot more plausible
that that french apartment that he lived
in
he lived in that apartment because his
favorite
bar
was uh
on the ground floor and a couple
just a couple uh a couple buildings up
the road you know so less than 100
meters maybe 25 30 meters something
so he could walk from his apartment down
that bar
and in that bar it was part of like the
french heroine scene
and he was evidently making a lot of
money selling heroin and dealing heroin
and he had gotten addicted to it
and evidently on the night in particular
he got a new shipment
of some product in and he went into the
bathroom in there and shot up to try it
and it was so good that it killed him
and he laid in there for a while
you know a half hour or so and
he he was friends with the owner and the
owner [ __ ] busted in to the stall and
they got him out of there and he'd been
dead
so the owner and his friends and and i
think his girl i think his girlfriend
carried him up the road through carried
him up the back alley to where he lived
and took him back to his apartment they
put him in bathtub [ __ ] hot water
trying to warm his body back up and then
they called the police and said he that
he died of alcohol poisoning in the
bathtub
and um the french authorities didn't
believe it they figured evidently the
french authorities knew it was heroin
but they didn't want to make him look
bad because they were kind of fans
so they said alcohol poison i mean
nobody killed him really no no so it's
not like they were letting a murderer
but that sounds a lot more plausible and
that
it came from pretty good sources and
that sounds more plausible how he died
and it was kind of typical of that era
they would die heroin overdoses but the
media would cover it up and say no it
was alcohol
so
that would mean that janice joplin maybe
even though she drank like a fish that
might have been might have been a heroin
overdose and maybe the same
maybe the same with jimi hendrix because
they claimed the same thing with him
that he died of alcohol
no proof but
yeah i mean you can still die of alcohol
yeah it's not crazy people die of it all
the time which means that von scott
maybe died of a heroin overdose it was
just
typical for them to if you died of a
heroin od that they'd try to cover it up
and say it was alcohol
because that sounds like not as bad not
as bad because at least alcohol is legal
i guess i don't know
um the thing is the thing is with jimi
hendrix is that he worked a lot
which is that's not typical of a heroin
addict
well well the thing about it though is
that that's not well because
that's not like true across the board
because some of them do work was a
heroin addict and he worked his [ __ ]
ass that he had like albums and novels
and [ __ ] he did all kind of crap i guess
some guys can resist he didn't sleep the
whole time right he did he put out a lot
of product when he was on that [ __ ]
amazingly and so did stephen taylor from
aerosmith stephen tyler stephen tyler
taylor
stephen tyler [ __ ] uh he put out a
lot of albums too but evidently [ __ ]
all of aerosmith was [ __ ] bad junkies
in in certain periods of time but then
they kind of snap out of it and make
some albums and
it was just there was heroin epidemics
during those times kind of come and go
yeah i mean a lot of people were kind of
onto that [ __ ]
but like i said it's not gonna affect
everybody the same yeah
you know most people
yeah they just kind of lay around and
sleep all the time
but apparently not everybody
and like uh to be honest like with
somebody like nick cave it's kind of
like he was admittedly uh you know a
junkie at the time but
his uh the quality of his output didn't
suffer like his albums from that period
were all like really really good
murder harness said he sent me some
flacca
okay really yeah man if you send me some
flock i'll do some flops don't you eat
my face off i'll be there be like
let me do the flock of dance that's the
floor we try to see if i can do flock
flock is like this
[Laughter]
is that that's that's uh that's how they
do flock okay flakka makes you repeat
yourself
oh my god
no no he's not teaching somebody flocka
he's just [ __ ] with me we were
[ __ ] cinnamon although how funny
would that be if he actually did send
you you don't have to send anybody flock
a flock because all of this place is not
worth anything
i mean yeah i think you can give flocka
for five dollars
really why would you do it
well some people do so they can think of
a reason [ __ ] bottom bottom of the
[ __ ] barrel
well if you want a barrel that's the
thing if you want to get [ __ ] up and
you only have five dollars i guess
that's kind of like the only it's not
like they have an option of getting
better [ __ ]
you know what i mean can't judge them
too harshly they're like look i want to
get [ __ ] up like the rich people
but i only have five dollars
here
take this stuff that'll make you eat
your friend's face off yeah and you'll
like it yeah you know what i mean and it
always looks different evidently well
there's kind of a thing where
i don't know i i kind of feel like
there's this weird thing where people
think that poor people shouldn't be
allowed to like enjoy themselves you
know what i mean
like they're not allowed flockable fry
your brain well i know i'm not saying
you should do flop
that doesn't follow from what i said but
i'm just saying that you know everybody
kind of has a right to
enjoy themselves however they want but
don't do flakka seriously
um
caitlin higgins says two thousand
dollars in la or near most coastal areas
probably only get you a studio apartment
yeah
i mean honestly it's getting like that
here too because
as i said yeah you can get you can find
a studio or a one bedroom maybe for
a grand or 1200 something like that
that's okay
but
sometimes it's going to be in kind of a
sketchy area so it's not that much
cheaper
apartments in general are not are not a
good deal
now years ago
before we moved in together so this was
like 11 years ago 11 or 12 years ago
i had an apartment in
winter park i looked down like it was
such a delay i saw the flock of dance
the [ __ ] dance was funny
i had an apartment at winter park that
was
one bedroom
and it was cheap it was only
uh what was it 6 50 680 something like
that but this was like
years ago team that jumps up april happy
april fool's day y'all this is [ __ ]
april tom's day it's april thomas day
what's up teeth
thank you teala yeah
but yeah so i i actually got that
apartment for like really cheap i think
it was six no 670 that's how much it was
which was
cheap even for then
now the apart the and i will say that
that because you went to that apartment
a few times the neighborhood was not
awful
but it wasn't really all that great
either like i never super felt like i
was gonna get murdered or anything
but
you know it wasn't somewhere it's just
kind of typical kind of just well most
of it was like college it was like ucf
students maisly because it wasn't that
far from ucf so a lot of it was just
like students yes tila i have usurped
the holiday
and dessert
it should be transnational now that it's
tom's day
okay oh just admit it
admit it you want every day and you
missed my flock of dance because i did
the flock of dancing
[Laughter]
fixing my belt
i know i was like i didn't understand if
that was part of the dance or if you
were just doing that for practical
reasons no that's that's that's what
that dude was doing oh okay
i haven't i don't watch videos
i'm gonna show you a real the real thing
i'll [ __ ] pull up that i mean i
remember you find it like i remember
watching it like a long time yeah i'll
show you oh yes man
like i said oh you know what don't you
eat my face off they're asking me about
[ __ ] meg and then they're [ __ ] uh
meg was that biker girl i posted a video
of her
she was actually up here oh i haven't
even seen that oh you see that what'd
you post it on instagram or facebook
both instagram i don't look at your damn
instagram um i can send it
i can send it to you if i send it to
your
messenger will you be able to put it on
the stream no okay how's that gonna work
i'm not gonna i can't do that i'm sure
there's probably just meg is showing her
sportster
her boyfriend is a builder down in uh
clearwater
okay
is he a scientologist no okay that's
good no she was funny though she was
talking about scientologists and stuff
oh so she yeah she knows all about it
yeah
well yeah i guess you would you kind of
have to live in a clear water because
they're [ __ ] everywhere like
cockroaches all right
see if i can turn the volume up i'll do
it just oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] it up i [ __ ] it up because
hold on i'll turn the earphones off
okay
she's in the process of being rebuilt
um eventually the whole engine will be
completely blacked out yeah um the
handlebars will be orange and we'll have
some orange and black accents going on
throughout the whole bike that's a nice
sportster i like it orange and black
it's kind of a rad bike right now but
like i said you can do what you want
with that all right yeah yeah how long
have you had that it's a bike builder he
works for beachbum customs llc in
clearwater all right
how long have you had it i have had this
bike for two years now oh okay cool
yeah all right well i'll put that up on
my instagram oh yeah thank you
okay brad says i'm in destin florida i
want to come down and party you guys
okay well you can if we if we ever have
a party we've been talking about having
a party at this [ __ ] place we
probably should get some furniture first
just meet us at the club
i didn't bring these strangers up in the
house
y'all might trash the place yeah
i'm gonna show this kid this cat here
got something this cat here has got some
nice titties
that
i was like and i told i turned around
and i told pookie i was like did you see
that daddy wants to put titties on you
yeah it's got something in the wig look
at the other pieces like what the [ __ ]
what
well i love how the cat with the tits is
just like yeah deal with it
i could never like get pookie to sit so
long and she'd be like [ __ ] that what
are you doing stop touching me
she tells us to shut up she needs to
shut up she's like you're not putting
boobs on me daddy okay that would be
really weird you're her dad i think last
week me and jenny went to the uh
to the um
to the japanese restaurant up the street
and i said i have that video yeah on
here you want me to show the video yeah
i
i meant to show it on the last show yeah
and then i got drunk and i forgot yeah
but i've had it all set up in here this
is
momiji momiji wrestling we've talked
about and like i said two miles down the
street eustis which is kind of it's not
as in the middle of nowhere as it used
to be yeah but it's still kind of in the
middle of nowhere yeah you'll have dudes
[ __ ] linemen and construction workers
and [ __ ] in there eating sushi all day
all times
but uh what do you what is that noise
okay yeah this is it this is it this is
it
i thought the audio was on for that
we'll figure it out try it again let me
try it again i see it see it says off
no no that's i'm not on that anymore i'm
not on it hold on hold on hold on when
you're getting ready to start oh yeah
okay
how's it going yeah okay this is
momiji's it is the local
sushi japanese sushi restaurant right at
the street from our house this has only
been here for a couple years but you can
check it out this is florida in the
middle of nowhere
um
[Music]
yep you got a good salad yeah i got my
soup just now we just now ordered so
yeah let me get not here yet i'm getting
shrimp tempura bento box that's what i'm
getting yeah i'm getting three get the
three uh sushi rolls
there you go that's what we're having
[Music]
all right you got the foods here it
looks great there we go that's jenny
[Laughter]
okay it works i just had it on the wrong
setting that's all it was
um yeah it is and actually like looking
at that uh again i was like oh now now i
want to like eat that shirt again it was
like so good
oscars asked me if i got the package
that he said i don't remember what
package that you sent which package was
it
i mean did we check the mail today uh no
i didn't check it today oh [ __ ] it might
be down there i mean the mail
you know the mailbox is so far
yeah
how good that food is that food is great
we haven't eaten there several times
because like i said it's right up the
street and we've never had a bad meal
there nope i mean and if you go during
the week it's a lot cheaper like if you
go for on a weekend or dinner it's like
kind of expensive but if you go like
during the week it's a lot cheaper
yeah
um i would say
and i've had japanese food everywhere
including you know boston
and uh
i've had it in new york but there isn't
any difference between japanese food in
boston new york really about to say
and i'd say it's it's on par there isn't
there isn't a substantial difference
between it
now what i showed you guys eating you
could go up to um
to a uh there's an all you can eat
buffet what's name that [ __ ] place
that we go to
uh
i can't remember yeah i know what you're
talking about though
koi wan koi wan
koi wan is big it's got an indoor [ __ ]
koi pond and like a river and little
japanese bridges that go over everything
it's a massive place yeah it's massive
and you can get
similar to what we we got in there
but
but it's not fresh it's not really fresh
it's my you know it's been sitting there
for a while
and you can just stuff yourself for
about 15 bucks
you know but it's it's
it's everywhere now you can find good
food anywhere
yeah and i like the old days it's not
like the old days
i there was good food [ __ ]
downtown hattiesburg mississippi which
that's [ __ ] nowhere
good chinese food you know good american
food dude whatever
yeah you can't really had an indian
restaurant there it's [ __ ] great
which is crazy because like when we were
growing up that night that never
happened that would have never happened
gram there's hammer's asking some more
questions yeah who gave better hand jobs
and blow jobs brazilian girls or trenton
girls
he had us he has to think about this for
a minute man they're both good
that's that's a pretty diplomatic yeah
they're both good
uh i don't think there was i don't think
there's a substantive difference really
teenagers are teenagers wherever they
are [ __ ] and [ __ ] teeny well i
kind of feel like teenage boys are just
kind of like hey as long as somebody's
touching my dick i'm not really like all
that
no
no
no i [ __ ] grant us knows exactly
where we had taste grab there's
taste we were discerning yeah we were
[ __ ] upper echelon [ __ ] back
in those days um
what was what was great in our era is
that um and it's probably still the same
way now
teenage girls of our generation were
into it i mean they gave it their
[ __ ] all you know uh it wasn't
it was like a big deal for them that
they were [ __ ] having sex so they
were gonna [ __ ] put they were trying to
impress you you know
when people get older it's [ __ ] you
know the women are kind of like yeah
this is the same old [ __ ]
yeah and i'm gonna say get the [ __ ] away
that's just the way it is but
you know [ __ ] teenage girls are gonna
like okay i'm ready let's go you know
why you like teenagers in general
because you've got [ __ ] to prove well
they're discovering things too so it's
just kind of like you're discovering
what you like maybe once you're like old
you already kind of like are established
you've had a lot of relationships it's
not really the same thing anymore so the
difference in the sex between north
americans and south americans is not
really at that in that age group there's
not a big difference what was different
is that brazilian girls
were a lot more mature for their age
because they were able to drink and go
to night clubs
way what would be considered way
underage for americans like they're in
there 15 14 years old drinking dancing
and living in an adult life at 14.
and it was normal there
you know um they weren't messing around
with adults they were messing around
with other teenagers but they're you
know going to nightclubs drinking out
you know drinking alcoholic drinks and
it was you know taking cabs and [ __ ]
they weren't they weren't even driving
but you know taxi cabs are everywhere so
they take cabs
so the difference
was is that
a 17 year old brazilian girl was kind of
like a 21 year old american girl in
terms of development
so you had to be on top of your game
um south american women are
uh especially brazilian women are
high in physicality you know phys and
prowess
uh the culture is a little bit different
women are a lot more aggressive because
it's not considered macho to in south
american culture to be pursuing women
you're supposed to be better than that
you're like a lion
just sitting there waiting for them to
come to you
and they do they're if you're if
if you're if you got game if you got
game they do
man and how do you have game in south
america you got to be good looking
handsome young and have a rich family
then you got game
and a car
yeah i had all that [ __ ] back in the day
but uh it's just a
i like south america you know it was a
is it's a great culture
uh i could go all throughout all of
south america and central america and
fit in
um
portuguese and la and and portuguese and
spanish are real close the cultures are
real similar
and no matter what you see you know
these cartel wars and all
central and south americans are a very
kind of warm-blooded and hot-blooded
people it's usually kind of man-to-man
person-to-person
you can talk your way into trouble or
out of trouble depending on what's
what's gone down i could go anywhere and
[ __ ] make it i mean i'm [ __ ]
confident i could even [ __ ] deal with
[ __ ] drug cartels and [ __ ] walk
out of it live make friends with them
because why because i'm not in a drug
trade
so i'm no threat to them
i would just go man that's a [ __ ]
badass gun dude you know really and then
start asking them questions about their
lives and how they got involved in this
and oh yeah
if you have empathy for anybody you can
make friends with anybody if you show
interest in them
and and just
and give them personal respect
because i don't know these dudes i don't
know how they got involved in that they
maybe they didn't choose that maybe they
were kind of forced into that but then
got into it over time and
you know
i don't know their backgrounds yeah you
never know anything you never know
exactly what happened so you don't just
go oh you're bad yeah you can get
yourself killed you do that to the to
the wrong person
you always listen to a person try to
figure out
who they are and where they come from
and give them the benefit of the town of
the doubt if you don't know him you know
but i can make friends with anybody
granthars also asks florida tourists
pain in the ass or endless economic
fountain why not both
uh i mean florida we don't really notice
them because everybody's kind of a
little bit from everywhere i mean yeah
and i mean the thing about it i think i
noticed tourists more
when i lived in daytona because they
were
you know every time it was spring break
or bike week or something like that they
were like you know drunkenly falling
onto my lawn and whatnot so i did like
actually notice them so they were much
more of a pain in the ass you couldn't
get to work you couldn't get to school
because everything was like the traffic
is backed up and honestly um
they
they do they are kind of a pain in the
ass because people come from everywhere
and then they try to drive on i4
and
i4 is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show although it's
better than it was because they've
widened it uh they actually did a lot of
you know they've done a lot of
construction on it the last couple years
which has actually um helped a lot and
sort of
you know made it like so the congestion
isn't as bad but
even still like driving out like to go
out saturday nights and stuff like that
you're still kind of taking your life in
your hands because half the people on
there are on something half the people
on there don't really know where they're
going because they're not from here and
then
there's another portion of people that
are just like [ __ ] crazy and said i'm
just gonna drive 120 miles an hour for
no [ __ ] reason and uh you know and
are just like weaving in and out for
you know for whatever reason
so yeah it's horrifying but uh yeah
they're they're a pain in the ass but
central florida that's like our main
uh
you know that's that's our kind of our
main
thing that we make money on so they have
to come here otherwise we're all kind of
in trouble
t says hello uh if i have sushi i need
lots of wasabi i'm horrible at japanese
food eater
i don't even like wasabi
i like some kind of sushi but not others
usually i'll pick something more like
um like i said i'll usually get like
tempura or something like that she says
i do love tiki restaurants the hawaiian
japanese fusion yeah there was a tiki
restaurant in southern california
we used to go to all the time when i was
a kid called kalbos
it's a legend now and it just looked
like a damn
lighthouse with a
bunch of hawaiian trees and you went in
there and it was just dark and damn
you could never have a restaurant like
that nowadays it would be a health
hazard but there's no damn [ __ ]
stuffed blowfish hanging from the
ceiling and [ __ ] divers and [ __ ] and
all these
stained glass windows of peanut butter
sandwiches [ __ ] smashed in them and
weird things you can find pictures of
cowboy
cowboys in there
the walls were like
bamboo walls they looked like they were
bamboo and then each little
booth was like a cubbyhole you go inside
and on the left was a drink menu and it
would light up like a like a lit up sign
and it was pretty you know
and
man it looked like it looked like a love
motels exactly what it looked like it
was tiki as [ __ ]
into that though yeah and it was dark in
there you know i mean it looks like you
get a you can get a [ __ ] in there
nobody knows nobody would notice but it
was like
it
it was a cool restaurant was fun
and it had a certain smell when you went
in there it smelled like barbecue sauce
barbecue sauce and [ __ ] whiskey
and they had real good barbecue sauce
and
they had egg rolls
the egg rolls about three feet long and
chopped up you could pick it up and eat
it and dunk it uh
open face barbecue sandwiches with
pineapple and [ __ ] barbecue sauce and
coleslaw on it and
um
chinese ribs chinese spare ribs so it
was like a mixture of
it was tiki you know which is 1940s
interpretation of what hawaii was there
wasn't [ __ ] hawaiian about it nothing
hawaiian about it
it was just cool restaurant it's gone
now though cowboys you can look it up
tila said my uncle always said i want a
woman i can take to the white house and
to the hood she's got to be versatile
that's kind of good for anybody i feel
like
uh noting for me too says low-level
functionaries in any legit or illegal
aren't npcs they're real people best way
to get in in and social engineer [ __ ] is
to treat people decently yeah i kind of
feel like that's true of any
i mean just don't be an ass right out of
the gate like yeah you know treat people
nice there's this famous video going
around right now about these two
american gay dudes they get stopped by
the drug cartels the jug cartels jump
out and [ __ ] point guns at them
because they were going down the wrong
road out in the middle of nowhere
and they're
freaking out and hyperventilating crying
and a drug cartel it's okay man it's
looking they're [ __ ] calm
drug cartels are calming them down
don't kill us don't kill us no it's okay
man so come in it's okay
they don't really they they just turn
them around
don't go down this road well it's like
hey don't point guns at me and maybe i
won't cry they know who they were yeah
they knew who they were
in spanish they're going they're lost
they're lost who are these guys and then
him they're lost and they they don't
speak they don't speak they would speak
spanish because he goes to their gringos
they're just you know yeah it's like
it's fine they're gringos
okay
yeah i'd be crying too so it's like a
whole bunch of people probably [ __ ]
guns at me
but people are people yeah you know
generally yeah well a lot of those
[ __ ] cartel execution videos they're
executing hit men that killed their
people so they do they show the extreme
malice most of it and some of that [ __ ]
that i've watched is [ __ ] biz you
know berserk being
i get videos from mexico
sometimes you know [ __ ] some khan
will send me some or [ __ ]
bee's nest will [ __ ] send me a video
of what they did they'll be cutting
people's arms off at the elbow with a
pocket knife you can hear the [ __ ]
blade scraping through the damn bone and
there's
some girl screaming you know they throw
her arm in front of her and [ __ ] you
know what i mean then cut the other arm
off and then [ __ ] slit her throat and
they're
bad
i mean i i couldn't do it
i couldn't do it i would really have to
hate somebody
a lot to get
fired up into such an injury yeah
i mean you have to be really bad you'd
have to really really hate him yeah
right
i mean i could probably if i hated
somebody i could see myself if i hated
somebody enough doing that but there has
to be some kind of i'd have to really
hate you right
because people are like well wait a
minute this is inhuman that's not the
way human nature is i've seen the
extremes of human nature
violence is usually goal directed
there's usually they're usually
trying to achieve something or or they
think it's justice that's why they're
doing it they don't think it's unfair
they think it's fair
it's it has to do with the point of view
um the things that boggle my mind is
when it's a serial killer doing it for
sexual gratification and he's getting
off on the fact that it that it is
unfair
i i can't i can't see that i just
i'm not down with that that's too cold
[ __ ] blooded
it's because it's the same thing these
dudes putting a damn cat in a cage
pouring gasoline on and setting it on
fire you know what i mean i'll put your
ass in that cage and set you on fire you
know it makes you that's what i feel
like i want to do
uh but they got dudes like grams out
there like federal agents and [ __ ] going
la catch your ass for doing this to that
i understand that because we're within a
we're within a framework of law
inside a
supposedly functioning civilization
well if you look at what's happening in
other countries where this weird shit's
going down there is no functioning
civilization really
the civilization is a facade
it's [ __ ] very very
a very very thin facade underneath it
it's actually
savagery um
if you kind of trace the money those
cartel guys are actually the authorities
because the people that are paying them
are elected officials or ruling
oligarchs who own the democracy that
people vote for
so they're supposedly voting for this
democracy but it's just window dressing
it's really those cartels and the
rich oligarchs that run those cartels
they're the real authorities
what
which means that it's
still kind of something medieval
you know
which makes a lot of sense because
that's a very robust form of government
it's been around for thousands of years
um
that's why
parts of central america are well
actually central america is like that
south america is like that
it's democratic
institutions are a
facade they're like thin facade
that's not the way it really is they're
oligarchies
they're the ultimate form of organized
crime
but more you find out about what's going
on here in the united states so are we
it's just that corporations are involved
in it our democracy isn't real it's just
to make it look good that's all let me
go get a
refill yeah everything tila says jenny i
rewatched mommy dearest and the devil
wears prada both are so good oh my god i
love mommy dearest so much i saw it a
million times on cable back in the day i
remember liking the devil wears prada
too i might have seen that in the
theater did i see that in the theater
i kind of feel like no maybe not
maybe not maybe i saw that on like
[ __ ] well i see the thing about it is
that i saw a lot of movies like i used
to work with a guy who used to pirate a
bunch of movies
so he would loan them to me all the time
so i saw like a bunch of movies that i
probably wouldn't have seen otherwise
and i think that was maybe one of them
but mommy dearest is absolutely my
favorite and i don't think i've ever um
i don't think i've ever read the book
i actually would like to because
that sounds like some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you
know
like that whole situation
i mean i wasn't there but
thank you victor
jenny getting her summer bud
[Laughter]
am i okay i don't know
dj maniac says and the edibles just
kicked in wee
huh
i made my drink for the show because i
just made it like half an hour before
the show started and i
thought i put a lot of vodka in it but
apparently i didn't because it wasn't
nearly as strong as when tom makes it so
i guess tom makes me drinks and tries to
like [ __ ]
get me super sloshed that's what he's
doing
murder hornet returns says no wire
hangers i mean
that movie is just so it's like it's a
camp classic
i mean the shit's not funny because
if that [ __ ] really happened like that
she like
really [ __ ] up those children and
that's terrible but
uh yeah mommy darris and devil wears are
really good double features over the top
both of them
all it's honestly all i remember from
devil wears prada
was
the revelation
that
oh thanks
that uh what's her name that was in it
not um
[ __ ]
she was just in that movie colossal that
i reviewed the other day what's that
name
that uh the revelation that she was uh
fat at a size six
which i was kind of like i mean i know
that they were like making fun of that
because like the fashion industry you're
supposed to be like super scrawny but
i was just kind of like really like
she's fat okay that's wow that's that's
terrible
[Laughter]
dj meenak says well i watched joan
crawford in anything
yeah have you seen you've seen mommy
dearest haven't you
a long time ago that's when they were
that she was abusing her bedridden
sister right no no no no that was uh
what was that hush-hush sweet charlotte
no no no that was the other one with
betty yeah no mommy dearest was the one
with um they done away with faye dunaway
yeah yeah about child abuse yay where
she was like beating up her daughter
christina her adopted dog yeah
and the son too but they didn't really
it was based on christina's memoir so it
was mostly about her
no need for me says take away the
electricity the comforts and scare the
[ __ ] out of people you see how quick
people turn into animals yes anne
hathaway thank you that was yes all you
gotta do is just look at looking katrina
and i was i was there
yeah
even the cops running
the cops taking their patrol cars and
running to [ __ ]
mississippi and [ __ ] texas
yeah
tila wants us to do a re-watch on mommy
dearest okay
we should probably i i really love that
movie
yeah i saw it a million times back in
the old days yeah whatever happened to
baby james whatever happened to baby
james that's what it was called yeah and
then well that i was thinking of the
other one with uh with uh betty davis in
it which was yeah
sweet charlotte which is also good
and betty davis was in
burnt offerings
when she was older remember that she
probably like the older aunt yeah i love
that movie i just reviewed the book not
too long ago too oh that's [ __ ] great
that's one of my favorite like uh
haunted house movies from the 70s and i
feel like a lot of people don't talk
about it and my face was looking swollen
in that video of me at the damn uh
uh [ __ ] restaurant
did my face look [ __ ] puffy
i think it did
my [ __ ] face look am i puffy face
looking puffy as [ __ ] he's always
he's like
do i look puffy
that [ __ ] test will [ __ ] blow you
up blow your face up make your [ __ ]
look like you're on a rag
yeah tom's on the rack yeah and they
give me the high blood pressure pills
which are diuretics that bodybuilders
use them to [ __ ] try to [ __ ] piss
out a lot of water so i have to like
double up and triple up
sometimes on them diuretic [ __ ]
little pills to [ __ ] keep my blood
pressure down low
if i can piss that [ __ ] out i need a tan
i need a tan i need to put on [ __ ] i
need to lose [ __ ] another 10 pounds
of [ __ ] fat put on like [ __ ] 15
pounds of muscle
i mean i'm gonna go on a [ __ ] diet
man
i'm getting i'm getting um
i'm
i'm getting what do you call it i don't
know what you call it getting a complex
you've always been complex
get
get a body of dysmorphia you are yeah
you get anorexia
you get a man wrecked him you are
tila said we'll just call you puff daddy
tom you don't look puffy though no look
puffy okay well maybe you thought maybe
you just perceived that because you
didn't have a hat on and like you know
so you just like your little bald head
yeah i was looking too much like bruce
willis
bruce willis hit his ball of face bruce
willis retired
because his uh i mean but bruce willis
is a lot older yeah he's a lot older and
he looks a lot older than you as well he
got to where bruce willis is yeah he
can't remember any of his lines and he's
having he's hitting mental decline well
he's got
a disease what is it called
uh well it just means you'd get memories
[ __ ] up but i think it's from [ __ ]
mini strokes or something
little strokes
and he can't remember his lines so he's
going to retire
um
which is good because he got to the
point where he'd be in any [ __ ] movie
he'd be he'd be in anything
and not in a fun way like nicolas cage
well right
and then um
the dude from sonic the hedgehog and the
dude from the mask what's his name jim
carrey he decided yeah today he
announced he's retired
i i'm i'm ambivalent about it yeah well
honestly that's he saw that [ __ ] he
saw a [ __ ] uh uh old chris [ __ ]
tucker get [ __ ] punched or snapped
and he and he he he it wasn't chris
tucker what was his name it was the
other one [ __ ] what's that dude chris
rocket yeah chris that other comedian
yeah [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] what's his name will
will smith will smith [ __ ] slapped
his ass which i'm not a hundred percent
convinced it was legit i think it might
have been staged there's something
[ __ ]
something sideways about it
but he [ __ ] punched him or snapped
him and then um
jim carrey came out and says he'd had
enough that
he says we're not the cool kids anymore
this [ __ ] sucks ellie's he's like
hollywood sucks says we're not the cool
kids anymore
which he's right
the thing about youtubers are youtubers
and [ __ ] cut and in fact youtubers
[ __ ] podcasters and [ __ ]
independent film people are now the cool
kids well youtubers even now we're
getting along in the tooth everybody
it's all about yeah
yeah tick tock
tick tock but see the thing is is that
tick-tock will have to expand
if those kids are going to have to
tick-tock i don't think you have law you
won't have a long life on tick-tock
no probably not because that seems i
mean i don't know it's you know i don't
like to like tell the future because i
don't [ __ ] know what's gonna happen
um
dj maniac says they just added ken
russell's the devils to shudder [ __ ]
what yeah
oh my god we're gonna have to like do a
matinee on that i love that [ __ ]
movie
uh victor garcia says during the winter
storm last year we lost power in texas i
ate my neighbor's dog on day two so yeah
there's people asking us if we've seen x
now bob apple says easily the best
horror movie of the year
victor said x was boring luckily i was
drunk watching it
i kind of wanted to go to the theater
and see it i mean it's like i don't know
i've heard like really mixed reviews
um
but i don't know we'll see we'll see i
do want to see it
betty davis was badass indeed she was
um
yeah so what did you talk about oliver
reed
because he was in uh his man would scare
me
i was giving michael caine and michael
kane was scared of me when i was a kid
yeah you need you really need to see
women in love if only well no look up on
youtube i'm sure somebody put it on
there put to look up women in love
naked wrestling scene i know i've seen
the scene or man
i can't even run with the context that
would have scared me that would have
scared me when i was a kid
i used to watch you know
he used to watch movies with him and
[ __ ] michael caine in it i'd be about
12
between 10
and actually probably between 10 and 14.
it didn't matter what the movie was
they'd start talking and they would do a
close-up on their faces i'd start
getting scared like like a monster was
going to [ __ ] jump out and give me
even though i'd seen the movie already
and knew something knew something wasn't
going to happen
oliver reed was real good at scaring you
well he he was a very intense yeah
person like something might happen i've
seen this movie before but maybe they'll
insert a scene right here
will jump out again
something happened this time maybe they
changed it i'd get perfect i understand
that as a kid because even like
sometimes uh thank you victor here's
some money for the cloverfield review i
[ __ ] love cloverfield oh well you're
very welcome right sit down
[Laughter]
okay write that [ __ ] up no i did close
review okay okay i wrote it did it yeah
i repeat it
showed up mexican superman
okay he says i heard the great vine the
chris rock and jodha word thing back in
the day maybe
maybe right
jaded maybe jada was [ __ ] his ex i
don't know people are saying you know
what he's a cuck and this and that i i
don't think that's what it is i think
they're
they're both pretty alpha i think it's
just that
i think they have a professional
relationship you know i think they're
more like exes they have kids together
so they just i think they're just
holding the fort together and they just
they date other people
but i don't think that
and they stand up for each other it's
just that what he did
i don't know man there's something about
it makes you think that it was that it
was staged because he didn't insult her
he just gi jane joke there's nothing to
that
she's bald
she lost her hair alopecia
but it doesn't matter she looks great
bald
well as i said even back in the 90s
because she was in with a movie review
not too long ago like tales from the
crypt demon night and she wasn't bald in
that but her hair was like i mean she
might as well have been it was like
really really short and that was like
when she was young
you know what i mean that was with that
might have been before they even got
married i can't even remember
nobody watches the [ __ ] oscars they
just don't
all right it's got terrible fun well
most i mean most people kind of like
just like well what did everybody wear
yeah like the next day you just want to
look at the pictures it's something from
it's something from another although i
didn't even do that this year the oscars
are something from another era
back when hollywood was the only game in
town
it's got a lot of competition now
the quality of the product's not good
the universe is opened up a lot
young people probably know what the
oscars are
the ratings for the [ __ ] past several
years have been [ __ ]
it's not a [ __ ]
serious thing you know what i mean
there it doesn't seem to be any
class to it or anything it's just kind
of boring
i mean i just look up the movies that
one because i'm like oh maybe i'll watch
those it's like they sound good you know
what i mean like something for old
people
but i'm not gonna sit through like a
four hour [ __ ] show of everybody like
sucking themselves off i kind of got a
feeling that
chris and will were like will's like man
i'm gonna win oscar this time and
nobody's gonna see it and he's like well
what we got to do is maybe we got to act
up and make a scene
and and and he's like yeah
and then later
will i think maybe ad lived that
and it [ __ ] maybe went over the
[ __ ] top
so i think there was an element of
reality but there may have been an
element of like we're going to do
something to get some attention and he
didn't really know which way it was
going to go well it worked and it would
have worked
because everybody saw it everybody saw
that will smith got an obstacle oscar
and [ __ ]
chris
everyone his shows are now selling out
they got [ __ ] some people paying
three grand to get special [ __ ]
tickets to come to go see him again it
worked so yeah so that goes back to p.t
barnum
where he says there's no such thing as
bad publicity
and
drama cells
all right but like i said other people
are like man [ __ ] this and then they
left
[Laughter]
to be honest retired like i heard about
you carries like i retire i heard about
it but i honestly i mean i'm i'm really
into movies and so a lot of times i'll
look up like who won just because i'm
interested to see like move and i was
like oh that sounds good maybe i'll
watch that if i haven't seen it
or oh good that one was dominated or
whatever but i'm not going to sit
through the whole show because it's
boring
um sometimes i'll look at pictures of
what like they're people's dresses and
stuff but i didn't even do that this
year because i'm kind of interested in
like fashion and stuff but other than
that like i heard about what happened
like i saw the headline and then i think
i thought about it for like two seconds
i'm like do i care enough to click on
that
nope i don't i can remember being a kid
i remember being a kid in the 70s
the oscars would be on and my mom would
have like it would be like a big deal
like it was [ __ ] like a seasonal
event like christmas because it was
when you were being channeled down
through television which only had like
four network channels and a couple of
local channels
everything that was on television was a
big idea well everybody was watching
everybody was watching it and that's
what your social media was but that's
not the and then everybody was talking
about it there yeah but like i said
everything is kind of like you know
diffused nowadays like everybody's into
their own [ __ ] that's not what it is
which like i said you know in some ways
maybe you could argue that like we've
lost some social cohesion because
everyone's not on the same page we're
not all watching the same [ __ ] but i
would argue that it's probably better
because at least
yeah there's a couple downsides but
honestly i kind of feel like it's better
that people there's so much [ __ ] out
there now that exactly what you like
you can find that and you can find a
bunch of other people that like that
same thing and you can just go into that
niche and go do whatever you want you've
democratized the market yeah i'm i like
that much better yeah it's a lot better
i don't really like and it's taking it's
taking money away from people that don't
deserve it and really
most of the old system does not deserve
that money
think about it
those hollywood
studios
if you look at their past catalog of
what they've been making over the
decades 90 of it is [ __ ]
movies that are forgotten
same thing over and over and over again
just [ __ ]
and it's because it came from an era
that was pre-television it was
television
based
it was television before television you
can't have that anymore you can't have
mass movie production of just random
[ __ ] and expect to survive and
compete in this
every one of those movies now has to be
a masterpiece in order to make it
and they can't make masterpieces not
anymore
not not the not well masterpieces are
still made but they're on a smaller
scale yeah not by those big studios at a
smaller scale masterpieces
are going to be very rare coming out of
a big studio they're going to be more
common coming out of [ __ ] independent
creators and very in smaller studios
outside independent studios well i've
always been a big advocate of if you're
a movie maker and like the thing about
movies that's different from a lot of
other creative endeavors obviously is
that you have like a large crew involved
so you have like a lot of people you
know if you're writing a book or
painting a painting it's just like one
person so it's their vision so you're
seeing that a movie is like a bunch of
people working together like a big team
so
it's not really yes the director gets
all the credit
but it's not really their entire
thing
so uh so i do kind of feel like
i don't know i
it's just movies that are good
it's just
it's kind of like lightning in a bottle
i've seen so many bad movies
that to be honest i'm always kind of
shocked when a movie that
like a movie comes out good because i
know i've seen
how badly it can go wrong
a movie now has a movie for it to be a
masterpiece really has to be the vision
of a very small amount of people it
can't be made by a committee unless it's
a whole movie and that they know the
formula to make a temple movie it has to
it has to conform to that formula you
can't do anything [ __ ] crazy with it
all right uh like the fast and furious
[ __ ] that we saw the the that ex with
the jason state them and this is those
are great it's just the tempo
yeah
there's there's nothing intelligent it's
just a big dumb nothing
i have intelligence say we did have fun
watching it but i don't remember a
single thing that happened to them no no
no
same thing with the meg
dumb as [ __ ] meg was dumb
good time a single thing they had a good
time
i had a good time i had a good time but
it wasn't memorable now masterpiece
and recent era
joker jugger was a masterpiece
yeah i still remember [ __ ] very
uncomfortable i was uncomfortable
through that most of that movie
yeah
but man and i got it somebody's somebody
sent it to me um
who sent me that
i haven't watched it yet because that
movie is not fun to watch but it's kind
of informative
it's a deep movie that's i don't mind
stuff that's not fun to watch like
sometimes it depends on what mood i'm in
sometimes i just want to watch something
fun usually if it's like it's later at
night and i'm tired like i've been
working all day it's like i don't really
want to like think too hard about
anything so i just wait usually i'll put
on like riff tracks or something like
that like last night
uh amazon prime
added the rift tracks version
of kingdom of the spider yeah yeah yeah
with the shot
it was
a delight yeah oh my god it was so
although okay i had forgotten this
because i saw kingdom of the spiders a
lot back in the 70s what did it come out
78 something like that oh yeah 76 maybe
i can't remember
um
did they not have
or
did animal cruelty laws not extend to
spiders because
it looks like they actually did kill a
[ __ ] ton of spiders
on that shoot
i'm just saying they ran over a bunch of
them
a bunch of them got squished by people's
and that honestly kind of upset me
because
i don't you know i know i'm weird but i
like spiders
um and i really didn't want to see them
like hurt and so i'm watching the movie
going god damn dude that looks like they
really killed an actual spider like it
just like squished it probably did
and
i thought that they wouldn't allow that
but maybe in the set i mean
when did like the the humane society
started doing like overseeing movies he
was looking out kingdom of the spiders
to only see [ __ ] only see the rift
tracks of kingdom of the spiders amazon
prime just out of it yeah yeah and i was
delighted because i was like oh my god
kingdom of the spiders that was like one
of those like killer animal movies that
i loved in the 70s yeah that food of the
gods about the rats orca
i love those guys i love that [ __ ] and
you just watch them riff on it you know
because it's it's better when they're
riffing on it
it is much more entertaining i have to
say trying to come up with another big
studio movie that i thought was a
masterpiece
painting game which is based on a real
[ __ ] crime
thing here in florida that was a
masterpiece
um what about dune
dune the new dune it was good i don't
know if it was a masterpiece i gotta see
the second one
it's not finished yet
um what about the new blade runner later
yeah i was gonna say that that was a
runner that was that yeah blade runner
two i loved that and that's right i
called that [ __ ] because i can't
remember all the numbers
oh 2049 yeah
see she had to [ __ ] pick up she had
to pick up the pieces let me [ __ ]
have that i'm gonna say okay look then
i'm not being an [ __ ]
i want everything to be correct but i
can name so many other masterpieces that
didn't come out of the hollywood studio
system all right
[ __ ]
oh empire the ants that was a good one
too bavarium was a [ __ ] masterpiece
god i loved it i love avarium
very original
um that's one of those movies that i
actually
that one kind of like shot to the top
that's one that i don't mind watching
like over and over and over again that
is a which is crazy i don't see an irish
movie very the director's irish okay i
thought it was made in ireland it's not
no i say yeah it's it's made in ireland
and i said the director's irish like
most of the actors ended our american
they're american but it's just i'm gonna
call it an irish movie i'm all right it
was
and it's a very well thought out
weird
movie
that holds up on multiple viewings it
gets better with multiple viewings well
yeah you pick up so much more you're
right i just loved the whole vibe of
that yeah
it's been it's a lot like them in some
ways kind of like predator you're coming
in contact with an alien creature but
this is far more insidious
and it's not just physical it's extra
dimensional
and it's [ __ ] your mind up and it's
making you raise its child
and it's just a [ __ ] great like a
cuckoo birthday yeah it's just a great
[ __ ] premise
um and then another [ __ ]
another [ __ ] masterpiece
same actress
art of self-defense
well you knew he was gonna bring that up
yeah i was gonna bring that up
kind of athlon says dark city dude i
keep telling him yeah yeah yeah you
would love dark city
you really need to see dark city it's
really really good that's like right in
your wheelhouse
i say check it out it's kind of like i
gotta check it out victor says train to
busan
i mean that's korean
train to busan is honestly
and we've talked about this before and i
just reviewed the host like the other
day
korean movies
kick ass at least the ones that we get
over here they're good yeah the ones
that catch our attention they were good
at zombie movies uh for a while the the
the sequel to trading the busan was okay
yeah it wasn't it didn't great you
didn't quite it wasn't great didn't
quite capture the first it was okay
though it was okay it's okay
um
korean zombie series kingdom was good
yeah it was yeah it was pretty yeah we
watched that
yeah that i liked that a lot um trying
to think of uh another
recent masterpieces
i see good [ __ ] all the time there's a
lot of good like i said most of my i
watch horror [ __ ] mostly but um
honestly yesterday and i have a review
of it coming out uh
on the seventh yeah
uh
it was an irish
horror comedy yeah called
extraordinary
and it is
it is so
good it is so charming and delightful
and hilarious
and everybody needs to watch it it's on
shutter watch it pain and gain is a
michael bay flick who does the
transformers and it does big he's known
for like big dominance
yeah c game
that's a masterpiece movie zack says
hereditary yeah i all agree with that i
[ __ ] love
hereditary i love her i i prefer
mid-summer mid-summer is awesome awesome
yeah both of those movies are awesome
so yeah and hugo said parasite is good
yeah parasite was amazing we said we
actually saw which one was that parasite
the korean film
about the face oh yeah
well like the the guy that it was bong
joon-ho he's the same guy that directed
parasite also directed the host right
and he also did memories of murder which
i'm going to be reviewing you saw the
host
you saw the host without me i didn't see
it i reviewed it i know you reviewed it
i didn't see it i've seen it a bunch of
times okay honestly i've seen it a bunch
of times
you would probably like it it's a
monster movie but it's not it's not
kaiju that he's not like super big he's
like about truck size
yeah but
the and i think i said this on my host
review but i was kind of like the korean
filmmakers at least the films that we
get over here
they seem to have a really they seem to
have a like a knack for combining genres
in a way that feels like they're not
combining genres does that make any
sense it's it just feels very like
organic they're just like yeah we're
doing it's a horror movie it's a rom-com
we're just like we're putting all this
[ __ ] in there and it doesn't really feel
weird or like unbalanced or anything it
just feels like
he's talking about lighthouse yeah
lighthouse was good god i love the light
we saw that in the theater we did yeah
and and we were there in a packed
theater too and people were tripped out
they're like what the [ __ ] especially
the end when he goes he looks into the
lighthouse looking like what the [ __ ]
did i just watch i'm like what the [ __ ]
i was into it they were fighting over
jacking off and everything i was i was
[ __ ] weird that's like almost exactly
the kind of movie drinking the
lighthouse [ __ ] [ __ ] fuel i love
that kind of [ __ ] i love that kind of
[ __ ] well like i said i didn't know
where fantasy in reality left off just
crazy [ __ ] out on the damn
lighthouse [ __ ]
out there [ __ ] on an island [ __ ]
man in a lighthouse i mean
like i said i love weird-ass movies if
you kind of come up with some like crazy
[ __ ] premise
and just like commit to that son commit
to it no oscar says i loved the wide
carnivorous sky review thank you very
much that was a really good book so i
guess it was you that recommended it um
but yeah that was excellent it was a
short story review
um so yeah i put that up i'm trying to
think of like what the next oh my next
one that's going up is
another book by adam neville who no one
gets out alive
so i'm putting that one up
okay i wanted to mention another one
this is uh one of my [ __ ]
favorite movies of all times by one of
my favorite directors and screenwriters
and [ __ ] just commentators of all
times john millie's
i've been picking apart over the [ __ ]
decades conan to understand everything
in the mythology behind conan because
milius is smart as [ __ ]
everything in conan meant something
and i was always trying to figure out
the scene where
valeria dies
conan pulls off his necklace which had
the wheel of suffering on it and he
throws it away and he puts on her
necklace which was the eye of the
serpent which i had already figured out
it was a fertility symbol they they're
talking about asherah
which you know millions is it has a
jewish background
and so he knows well
the garden of eden's story
and asherah who was the serpent who was
originally el shaddai's wife who got
demoted later on into a serpent so i
knew it was a fertility symbol
and then and then as it goes i'm just
like well okay so why okay she died and
he wears the fertility symbol where's
the moral to this lesson
there was a deleted scene
and it's there you can find it on
youtube
he talks to subatai about spring
and when he was a kid
and he's and he goes i remember my
father used to take me out and the
spring one would blow and the smell of
the spring and it was 20 years i've been
fighting and killing for nothing and he
goes it's not too late for us super
tight and [ __ ] and i was going and i
was going there it was there it was it
was all the fertility references
that's where
it was
when
conan [ __ ] goes
outside and
and goes beyond the struggle for
survival from the masculine
perspective
and he embraces the sacred feminine he
now understands
uh introspection and and realizes that
the secret to life is to outlive your
own life reproduction
which is only creation instead of
destruction exactly that only can come
from woman and he learned that
from seeing
um
valeria's sacrifice
you know yeah and uh he goes and then he
tells super tight it's not too late for
us
we can have children and live forever
that was the that was the lesson but
then super tight says nah i'm drawn to
this life
yeah i'm just going to keep on killing
[ __ ] yeah
we'll have fun though because i'm drawn
to this life
and i'll always be in a position like
this
and if and if it's not and if you aren't
here chances are it'll be some with
somebody worse than you
and [ __ ] conan laughs he's like yeah
maybe
but that was that was the lesson so i
was wondering where it was because i
never said sell amelia short i'm like
milius where's the lesson because every
other [ __ ]
story he's very well versed in mythology
yeah yeah exactly
he's been [ __ ] hanging out with
campbell a lot of storytellers are like
people that write novels and stuff like
that it's like you know a lot of them
are usually like interested in other
people's stories and mythology and
things like that so you should have
never cut that scene just good on
youtube and go conan deleted scene well
it wasn't even long it was only like a
couple of minutes and i think the reason
why they cut it is because arnold's
pronunciation wasn't all that good
was like [ __ ] i didn't notice
yeah wait his accent you know how you
know how they were back in in the
[ __ ] early age they're like you're
not like you're english you don't sound
like you're from california right yeah
you sound like an austrian not right
that's what made arnie great in conan
well that's what made him stand out like
other than like the being a big muscle
bound and everything but it's like yeah
him being austrian yeah it's like a
whole other he's gonna sound like he's
from [ __ ] encino
that he's from [ __ ] san francisco no
he's from from far away place and in
[ __ ] california talk man yeah yeah
just talk like he does right you know
right
he loves [ __ ] arnie back in the
[ __ ] back in that era of arniness she
said she just dripping hardiness that
aren't in g that he was dripping
[ __ ] um arnie looked good
in conan one he looked good on conan too
but i have to say when he lost about 30
pounds of muscle
and he was in predator one i think
actually that's when he looked the best
when he actually lost he looked great
then too he was 42 i think at that point
41.42
tila said that she just also watched
enter the dragon for the first time
yesterday and then bruce lee with little
hearts in the eyes yeah you know i've
never seen any of his movies you've
never seen etter the dragon i've only
seen the one where he have i yelled at
you about this before the one where he
goes up the damn
tower and fights that's game of death
game of death and that was the one that
they made like after he died so they
only had like so much footage
actually i mean enter the dragon that's
like i kind of feel like you have to see
that it's illegal not to see it i've
never seen it i feel like you need it
i've seen more bruce playtacion
more bruce ploitation bruce lee movies
like bruce lye yeah li i've seen that
one bruce lee with three e's yeah
there's a whole it's a whole sub genre
the one where he goes to [ __ ] the
after world down in hell remember that
one that was a good one too and and even
fights he fights he fights everywhere he
fights dracula what is that frankenstein
and no frankenstein but there are
mummies there's mommies in here um and
he fights clint eastwood clinton fights
clint eastwood elvis yeah i think so i
think he does yeah what was the name of
that one [ __ ] wasn't even that big and
then you find the third leg of bruce lee
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was just
[ __ ] crazy what was the name of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] we watched that a few years
ago and i was just kind of like i think
this might be the most awesome film ever
made yeah
it's a bruce playtation film
but i can't it has like a pretty it
doesn't have like a cool title or
anything like that
but
yeah bruce lee she's asking what that
movie is called i'm trying to remember
goddammit what's the name of it i
remember like posting about it at the
time that we watched it because a couple
years ago yeah and i was just and i and
i was like blah and i was like writing
about it as we were watching it
and i was just kind of like
okay so bruce lee dies and he goes to
the afterlife but it's a different dude
because obviously bruce lee was dead
uh so he had some kind of excuse for why
he looked like a different dude now yeah
in
the after world and then he met a dude
that was
supposed to be clint eastwood
in what pale ryder if he had the poncho
yeah
so but they didn't call him that but you
know what i mean so he was that and then
i kind of feel like was it elvis who was
in it well like he met like all these
famous people
popeye i think popeye might have been in
there too and i'm not i'm not kidding i
think popeye might have been in there
and
he fights
dracula and then there's like an army of
mommies
at some point like i think that's toward
the end
it's one of the craziest it's super
entertaining though but it's one of the
craziest things i've ever seen because
and i was just like we were watching it
and it's like every new revelation i was
just like oh and now there's mummies
okay
all right i'm just rolling with it
at that point i was just kind of like
just whatever whatever you gonna throw
at me mommy but um i i was just kind of
like i don't know i don't even remember
what that movie's called zach is kinda
asking me indirectly if i thought no
time to die was a masterpiece i would
say
was no time to die a masterpiece
it was a masterpiece in a certain way
they had to write the story around
certain things
and still be able to get the message
that they wanted to get out
you see what that message is i see
exactly what they're talking about
they had to get that message out
and still avoid
any
trouble in politics
and then they also wanted to homage the
whole the old series
pookie
boy she's making a lot of noise that's
just she got her a little oh she's got
the little roll she's got her little uh
her little tree it's a little cat
that like it's like a really like a
weeble or something some people have
treats in it some people really talk
[ __ ] about no time to die and i just
don't agree i liked it a lot i liked it
they i think they did a nice job of like
wrapping up the daniel craig era
some people were like oh he died and
felix died and everybody died and this
what do you expect they have to die this
is what you deal with it this is movie
five sure
it's been going on for a long time this
this cast has to stop
you can't have a situation where you got
a [ __ ] 65 year old james bond well
and everybody knew that he wasn't going
to do any more james bond right so it's
kind of like i kind of feel like
everybody should have seen that coming
right they're going to wrap up that era
which like i said that's fair enough so
you have to give bond and felix an
honorable end yeah
and
i wish felix should have wished felix
was in all the movies
that particular actor i don't remember
his name anymore but i think he did a
great felix aaron and there's yeah i
liked him
there's been several phoenix felixes
over the the over the span of james bond
one of the felix's was black and that
was actually the most
physically impressive ones the other
felix's were
comedic relief or unforgettable
one of the more recent felix was just
kind of like an american dude who was
just like james bond so
that really didn't work either
the the daniel craig felix i thought was
the best handling of the character they
got the the casting was perfect that was
the actor you needed they did a really
good i mean they they did a good job
like establishing an emotional
connection between the two
so like when felix died yeah it was
really upsetting like i was upset well
he's well somebody says somebody called
him brother a bad guy called him brother
and he says i had a brother once his
name was felix and [ __ ] then he
killed that guy because that guy killed
felix betrayed him
um which
that was great because through the whole
series
bond had no male friends
he was very much uh i mean he had like i
guess mega type man well because of his
line of work sigma type man he really
had to kind of like keep his uh
friendships to a minimum yeah the only
guy like him was felix
and i thought that was a
a great
crypto bromance which they showed some
of that in the end with the [ __ ] coin
games and the the bartering and
bond joins [ __ ] cia temporarily
because am i [ __ ] six [ __ ] him over
it was it was it was a great hit now you
make me want to watch that one again
yeah he's selling the theater but i
haven't seen it at home then i own it oh
that's right you bought it i own it yeah
so i liked it a lot i did
but that was that was the great handling
and when he died
felix kind of laughed it off because
i guess he wasn't on our side you know
he had real good lines
you know
yeah i think they i think they did a
really good job with your character and
you see well this actor he's not famous
yeah he was in shaft
he was in the first
um a shaft that had um
oh [ __ ] man my [ __ ] head injuries in
my dream but what was the last shaft
that we had
[ __ ]
that last shaft [ __ ] was great uh i
think it was just
yeah the first the first samuel l
jackson shaft that guy's in it
that's right he was in there he was
doing that i totally forgot right so he
saw that in the theater he has he he had
a spy movie heritage
which allowed him to be cast as felix
that way he's not just some dude that
they pulled out he he was in shaft so
yeah that was the right the casting was
great
and um [ __ ] casino reality kicked ass
[ __ ] he wasn't in this quantum of
solace but he was in i think he was in
skyfall briefly
i have to watch all of them again
yeah
i mean coming back yeah he did turn up
and like most of them i don't yeah i
don't he might not have been in quantum
go solace and it's interesting because
quantum of solids i the first time i saw
it i really did not like it um it was my
least favorite i mean it's still my
least favorite but multiple feelings
build that one up but it i liked it
better the second time i wore it like i
said a lot of movies
i mean if you don't like if they don't
make you want to [ __ ] throw up the
first time you see them then if you
watch them the second time
um a lot of times you get a greater
appreciation i tend to like movies
better the second time i watch them
quantum solace was a little bit more
like one of the older james bond movies
true okay sure i will give it that so
it's kind of slightly an homage
but the director
did some really slick things
with alchemy
and references to the paranormal in that
movie a lot of people don't catch it
when he gets down to south america
that he's trying to stop an ngo from
stealing the nation's [ __ ] water
supply
through
malfeasance what he's taught what
they're talking about there are these
ngos that do this and american ngos that
do american-based ngos that do this to
south america
they've been doing it for a long time
been researching it goes all the way
back to the 1800s or the banana wars
okay
my mexican friends in there will tell
you [ __ ] we were launching war
colonel butler a
marine guard general butler
wrote a whole book about it called war
as a rocket back in the [ __ ] late
1800s about the [ __ ] south central
american government he collapsed over
banana prices
and we were ruthless country back then
anyway an ngo's trying to steal a
[ __ ] country's water supply so they
can fuel spectre
but you don't know who specter is at
this point it's like a one world
government that's forming but it's
really just criminals trying to steal
and they're camouflaged as good guys but
that's not who they are
it'll all look very familiar it looks
like the wef all right
so anyway
he jumps into a cab at a random spot and
the cab driver says i dreamt my dead
mother [ __ ] spoke to me and she said
that she she said that the water was all
going to dry up and it's just and he
says he says in spanish
not in english he says it in spanish you
have to understand some spanish
which that's weird the movie said you
can have visitations from the [ __ ]
dead and warning you about [ __ ]
impending doom in your dreams
i [ __ ] really like that part because
i had weird [ __ ] like that happened to
me and then later on he's in the [ __ ]
bad guy's base
which is a [ __ ] base in the middle of
nowhere using hydrogen it's on top of a
[ __ ]
water deposit and they're using it for
fuel and oil so there's this water and
fire motif happening in possibility two
opposites happening so it's kind of like
alchemical
symbolism happening in this big [ __ ]
shootout in the middle of the desert
and it's like something out of damn mars
if it looks like you see the movie
you'll like it you're like if you
understand this the symbolism it's kind
of a yin-yang symbol
and in the end
bond gets the bad guy who tried to steal
the water and lets him go to the desert
and he goes man [ __ ] and he goes here
drink this he [ __ ] throws him an oil
can
and they find him later on dead out that
was my favorite part yeah
[Laughter]
he's like [ __ ] your drink [ __ ] drink
this [ __ ] you steal the water drink oil
and they find his ass dead out in the
[ __ ]
die in a thirst out in the [ __ ]
desert for the [ __ ] empty oil can in
his hand and a [ __ ] belly full of
[ __ ] black
black oil he did drink it he drank the
oil he's like i was kidding don't really
drink that he drank it uh tila says oh
jenny i got those mint toys for my boys
for kitties yeah those words and they
love them yes i told you immediately
start picking them up and placing them
throughout the house they don't want to
share yeah you guys minties
minty's they're so i get them from
chewie they're like two bucks each yeah
they're these little
like sticks they're squishy they're soft
they're fabric
and then they have like little mint leaf
things at the ends and they have mint in
them
for whatever reason the cats [ __ ]
love them i don't like i'm sure every
cat doesn't love them but our two cats
are super into them so i buy new ones
like every
few weeks or so because you know they
play with them so much that they get all
like gross
but they pick them up in one hand like
pookie picks them up one hand and like
they just rub it on their faces oh my
god this is the best thing ever
best thing ever
and i still have a new one over there
it's still attached to the card and
pookie will jump up on my desk and like
try to get that so you know what i mean
yes you're right straw dogs his brother
from langley yes that's a good term
kellen higgins says no time to die i
felt definitive bond in terms of
cinematography and production design
like it could have been made in the 60s
or 70s yeah and i believe it was they
were homagin they did a lot of women and
honestly i think they did a really good
job because they had a lot of things to
like tie up
a lot of loose ends to tie up and i
think they did a really good job
homaging stuff without being like
overtly cute about it yeah like look
we're you know harkening back to
whatever i just and it was a good movie
like that worked on its own i think they
did a really good job with that one i
really do okay i need you guys to do me
a favor
tila's looking for the movie
that has [ __ ] uh look that up look it
up
lee in the underworld
exploitation
the third leg of fighting mummies or
something he fights dracula he fights i
think it's called
wait is jesse james in it
i think jesse j i think he fights jesse
james does he fight jesse james he
fights about that popeye's in there too
right now he fights
popeye
and the comedic relief is a chinese um
uh laurel and hardy oh that's right i
forgot yeah they're in the two there too
we sound like we're making this up i
guarantee you we're starving he's a real
man bruce lee is dead it's a real movie
so he goes to the chinese underworld and
continues to fight all the bad asses who
are dead
except it's a different dude but they
have an explanation they have an
explanation why it looks different
they look different yeah it's [ __ ]
hilarious and actually the writing is
real good
it's super energy real good yeah like i
said we sound like we're making
bruce lee saying that
oh oh the godfather's in it too yeah he
fights the godfather that's right
yeah yeah the godfather they don't have
enough cupcakes i'm not making this up
i'm yeah he fights
and
they don't have enough caucasian actors
to go around so some of these
some of these roles are played by
chinese or taiwanese chinese [ __ ]
it's a great movie it's hilarious it's
super fun it's [ __ ] hilarious they
know it's funny the mummies were my
favorite yeah yeah yeah because i was
like oh and now there's mummies yeah
like there's a bunch of mummies
yeah
yeah it's like there's there's no
consideration no no no nobody's coming
back with it look it up i'm gonna look
what it is it does it doesn't have like
a real memorable title that's all about
the same
that's why i always forget it
but i remember us watching that and i
was like this might be the greatest
movie ever made
just because when i tell people about it
they think i'm making it up and i assure
you i'm not making it up i'm not making
it up this is a real movie it's a real
movie
but yeah it's super fun
um
yeah i'm trying to think like i kind of
feel like he fought
laurel hardy was in it
clint eastwood was in it
i can't remember it was elvis or
somebody like that
and then
it's called the dragon lives again there
it is there you go the dragon lives
again yeah there you go
you sure that's the right one i believe
so because that i just look at the third
leg of bruce lee that good it goes
although that might have been more than
one movie okay and that and it's called
the does he fight but he fights mommy
he's fighting the dragon he's fighting
dracula it's called the dragon lives
again okay there you go
dragon lives again yep
yeah so it's not like a super memorable
title
seriously watch it yeah it's good it's
good
you will not believe
everything holy parish found it the
dragon lives again 1977. every single
thing that happens we were watching this
one night like you completely kept
commenting i was just like oh we're
doing this okay all right it kept
topping itself i was like wait a minute
hold on what i see what you're doing it
took me a while to get into it
it took me a while to understand the
premise
because i was taking it seriously
we'll see don't ever do and i didn't and
they had they just let it just let it
unfold they had the they had the emperor
of the celestial emperor there and i
didn't know what they were talking about
the celestial emperor is like a chinese
emperor with a hat with a bunch of beads
hanging in front of his face oh that's
right yeah and and they're talking about
the first emperor of china and he would
be in the after world and he's he's he's
basically the devil in the after world
crossing the devil and the and god
and uh he meets bruce when he comes into
the after world in a bar
in the afternoon that's right and and he
puts him on a mission
but you don't really understand it if
you don't understand
chinese culture you don't have to though
but you understand it well if somebody
had told me that he was in the after
work life
and this is chinese hell
or the chinese underworld it's kind of
like the chinese underworld they may
have it took me what i understand oh
okay he's he's fighting dead people
well the thing about it though is that
he's fighting dead people but a lot of
them are fictional characters
and there doesn't really seem to be any
distinction made between actual dead
people
and fictional characters
so there's that but i think that's kind
of what makes it fun i mean my favorite
part was him fighting all the mummies i
don't because i wasn't expecting mommies
what you don't expect mommies in a bruce
because there's more than one and
there's like one scene he's like out in
a [ __ ]
it's like a kind of beach with like
rocks kind of situation and then like
all these [ __ ]
the mummies are obviously like dudes
that are like covered with like [ __ ]
toilet paper or whatever
and then he just like starts doing kung
fu on the mummies and i said to tom i
turned to and i was like we were kind of
drunk at the time and i was just kind of
like oh so now there's mummies so this
is happening all right um i'm rolling
with it i'm rolling with it
um is film called deadly hands of kung
fu no it's not that it uh yeah somebody
said earlier yeah the dragon lives again
that's what it's called
the dragon lives again
like i said i remembered
see i remembered all the details of it
but i remember that the title of it
wasn't all that memorable that's why i
always forget because there's a whole
sub genre in case you didn't know
of brewsploitation movies bruce lee only
made
three whole movies and won kind of half
a movie because he died
you know and so they made game of death
which kind of had like half footage of
him and half other [ __ ]
so
because he was so popular around the
world there was a whole sub-genre of
bruce lee knockoff movies
um so you have like all these people
like pretending to be him and like you
said you had bruce lee li
bruce lee with one e
bruce lee with three e's like there was
all kind of like
there was probably like bruce
b-r-o-o-c-e i don't know but so there
was like a lot of like uh knock-off
movies so it was a whole [ __ ]
sub-genre which is crazy and i haven't
seen like a lot of them but
that's kind of like the most notorious
one
um
but
as far as i know uh the most
entertaining in case you didn't know too
uh i thought i'd
bring this this is kind of like
tangential but it's still kind of like
related
so if you guys didn't know there is also
a
really active uh sub-genre in turkey
of doing rip-offs
of american movies so there is a turkish
star wars there's the turkish batman
there's a turkish spider-man like any
big franchise you can think of it like
in american films
uh the turks have made like a knock off
of it
and it's usually like
super super low budget
and
let's just say a lot of the uh nuances
are lost in translation because
with the turkish
spider-man i want to say the turkish
spider-man
has
wait is it turkish spider-man or turkish
batman
i think it's turkish batman
that has batman and robin going to a
strip club and like being bad guys and
killing people right
he's got his [ __ ] sucker hat on yeah
that's right oh and his eye patches
well i got i got tila in the audience i
know that it affects that woman so the
the thing is about about the turks is
they're not really sure
they have a hard time uh understanding
the the line between good guy and beggar
you see spider-man well he must be a bad
guy look at him he's a spider look at
that outfit he's the batman
yeah he's got to be a bad guy look at
him you know that that's that's you know
that's no need for me too says brandon
tennold covers that suffocation yeah we
love brandon 10 old yeah he's good uh
and he covers yeah he's awesome he's a
canadian uh youtuber
and he covers a lot of
turkish knockoff [ __ ] he's super into
godzilla movies too so he did like a lot
of uh kaiju movies but he does a lot of
turkish knockoffs too and it's like
super funny and he's a big fan of
mystery science theater so he does a
similar thing where he kind of like
shows clips from the movie and kind of
riffs on them and it's like super now
here you go earlier on was saying that i
used the term masterpiece quite loosely
you do kind of i'm gonna say [ __ ] off
you do kind of here's the thing there
can be several
there can be several masterpieces a year
a lot of it has to do
with the genre
okay
pain and gain is a masterpiece
because it's in the true crime genre
see
that's
one of the best true crime genres it's
michael bay and this shit's [ __ ]
funny and it's a florida movie and i'm
gonna say
that's my interpretation of it is that
that's a masterpiece of true crime i
liked that movie because even though i
will say
even though it's based on a real thing
that happened which
actual real people got killed and that's
like [ __ ] up and i like i understand
they made like a dark comedy about it
but
they changed enough of the details
to
and a lot of the people that were
involved were kind of like criminals
anyway yeah so it kind of like it was
okay
but it had that real kind of like really
like pitch black humor yeah that i
really really and i i think i think
i think fighting with my family
was a masterpiece
of his genre
which was a true story about wrestlers
doesn't matter but you could kind of say
like what did yeah what genre was that
it was like a sports sports drama
dramedy yeah
[Music]
and
it was like if you're into that kind of
[ __ ] then you would love it
if you're into page
and female wrestlers you'd love it it's
a good story and the rock makes a
[ __ ] cameo
and it's partly happening in england and
part of it is in orlando florida and
it's it's kind of true to life to both
cultures and it's just fun movie
fun movie
i mean not everything has to be citizen
kane it could be a masterpiece
true well that's what i mean i kind of
feel like that's why it's so hard for me
to like
think of oh what are the best movies
ever what are your favorite movies ever
i'm like well what genre are we talking
about
i mean
right i could easily pick my favorite
horror movies
but
my favorite horror movies are very
different than my favorite comedies yeah
my favorite drama movies i kind of feel
like we need to judge things
by the standards of their own genre
right and then like across
it's you know it's objective or you know
it's subjective
subjective um
i think daniel craig james bond series
is a masterpiece series
of
of
spy based
commentary
spy movies with uh modern commentary
over things that are relative up to
today
told within a style that makes
things real
um
exciting you know what i mean uh the
introduction of spectre and what it is
and who it is that they're talking about
a lot of it has to do with corporate
stuff and
um nwo type stuff
and it was it but bond was always that
always that
and [ __ ] was corporate oligarchs
doing that yeah i mean i kind of feel
like that's been part of the series
right it was written right but here's
the thing because it's not new it's not
new
ian fleming
who was a member of oss is
who was you know proto kind of prototype
cia
knew who
bilderbergers were
and he talked about them and he said
they were dangerous and he but it's true
oligarchs are always dangerous they have
their own things that they want to do
they have money uh they can bribe people
they can do whatever they want they can
make up their own technologies they
can acquire power
that's been true for like true forever
ever forever
power corrupts
people and um
and instead of using armies of soldiers
they use armies of lawyers and that's
always been [ __ ] true
and ian fleming said we got to keep an
eye on that it's like runaway
corporatism and capitalism and run away
oligarchy and
yeah that's a reality
so
what i'm getting at is that you can say
well that's all conspiracy theory man
everything is a conspiracy the civil war
was a conspiracy
of plantation owners to break away from
the [ __ ] north
because they had to protect their own
wealth
and people tend to protect their own
wealth in their own own interests and
they have to have the money to buy the
power they do it
and it doesn't even matter if the poor
people in the south
were being [ __ ] over by by plantations
they didn't care it was plantation
owners they had the money and the power
and that's really kind of the same thing
james bond is about money and power
so
if you look at the daniel craig series
somebody said well they didn't do this
no they didn't do that or oh it's too
much this and that that's all feminine
the general
truth of the story
that goes back to even what [ __ ]
ian fleming was talking about
is stance that's what ian fleming was
talking about and
there's all kinds of things to learn
from that series
i think it's a masterpiece series
especially with the limitations of today
there's ratings
they want things to be pg they
although i would argue i know a lot of
people like whine about this nowadays
yeah but i would argue
that you can get away with a lot more
movies
that you could back in the day i mean it
depends on what you're talking about
though if you're talking about like big
hollywood movies
um
people pissed and moaned about
[ __ ] that nobody would talk about
nowadays back in the 70s and 80s oh we
have to give this an r rating or we have
to give this pg well pg-13 didn't come
in until the mid 80s
but
you know look at [ __ ] gremlins for
christ's sake
gremlins there was like a big deal about
that they had to do like a whole new
rating system for that because it's like
oh it's too gory it's like for kids or
whatever but it's like nowadays if
gremlins came out now
that would probably just be like pg
yeah to be honest with you even though
it's pretty gory but
back then it was like a huge controversy
yeah
i don't know and like i said people piss
and moan but like i've seen some [ __ ]
nowadays like okay what was that movie
we saw a year or two ago good boys yeah
which was a comedy and it was about a
bunch of children
doing
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah that was a
good movie though like i know it was
hilarious you know what's funny is that
a lot of people saw a lot of commentary
about that and they're like there's hope
for the future people were saying like
that because in a lot of ways that was
like something you saw in the 80s of the
90s
people are still moving so yeah the fact
that people wanted oh nobody would make
that nowadays i'm like have you seen
good boys yeah good boys was [ __ ]
good because funny as [ __ ] it was about
a bunch of little children
little kids doing really [ __ ] up adult
[ __ ] all sexual [ __ ] all that kind of
stuff
um
and it was hysterical people ask me if
we is weed legal in florida is it i
think medically it might be yeah but i'm
here about you gotta ask if something's
legal don't come here
if you gotta ask if something's legal
don't come here
i mean everyone just kind of does it
people just do whatever they want to do
here even back in the 80s they just
would like cocaine out [ __ ] a snort in
the club
okay
no just because it's legal i mean it
doesn't mean anything just don't get in
trouble
don't cause trouble
don't shoot people don't steal
make friends with people
get into a [ __ ] click
all right
don't be an [ __ ] and you would love
florida
everybody people get along here pretty
much good state well i mean pretty much
it depends even at the damn biker bar
one third of those people are not from
here
real heavy north eastern accents well
like i said florida is we're kind of
like
it's kind of like the south
but not really because it's people from
everywhere because everybody moves here
i'm going to say the weather i'm going
to say it's the south
it is but south it's the south tempered
by
it's the south and the people that are
are moving to the south
and becoming part of
the scene
it's going to be different wherever you
are
people coming from the north going into
a goth club are conforming to people
that are in that golf club
people that have moved from the north
moving into a biker bar out here are
conforming in a way and fitting in to
southerners in that damn biker bar
it's just
they're not imposing on us they are
fitting in with us
i know southern culture
i know the accents i know from all
across this country
one third of those dudes in that [ __ ]
biker bar that i [ __ ] go to during
the day
are what we would call yankees but
they're not causing trouble and they
understand southern culture and they're
fitting in and buying motorcycles and
and
listening to music and they're not
throwing their weight around and they're
and
there's a packing order in that
particular bar
all right it's not so much that in say
more urban goths
club setting not the same at all
in the god scene the southern angle
doesn't really come into play in a biker
scene it does
yeah and nobody cares about it and it
got in a galaxy because it's not
anything to do with that you got
foreigners coming in they're like yeah
yeah you're from france or whatever it's
it's it's a much yeah it's it's much
different well and the thing about it is
like if like goth culture is more like
if you're into that same kind of [ __ ] it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter where
you're from right it doesn't matter
where you're from you don't need to like
flicks about like you're from here or
there the other place if you like some
cool [ __ ] and you look cool then
everyone's just kind of like all right
right then they'll then you'll be fine
with it right
so it's a very different scene than say
the biker scene
yeah especially around here the biker
scene they're listening to country music
and [ __ ] [ __ ] that even i don't even
really like
i gotta [ __ ] play [ __ ] on the jukebox
and if you do the jukebox do the [ __ ]
through through the [ __ ] tablets i
got a [ __ ] i got they got a good
jukebox there
but i play a lot of motorhead
which they can't really [ __ ] with that
because that's british biker music and
then i'll put in some [ __ ]
um
metal 80s metal i'll put in [ __ ] old
judas priest and stuff
they don't they're they're they're
tending towards country but that's
really more their age bracket not so
much their class
if you know what i'm talking about
guys my age grew up in mississippi
didn't listen to country music listen to
metal
okay
well i think it was the older dudes
listening to the country as somebody
that grew up uh in daytona beach aka the
redneck riviera yeah
um
redneckery was very much the order of
the dead yeah it was just kind of like
the mainstream culture where i grew up
right so i do not i don't have a lot of
patience for it because i grew up with
it and i'm just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] that
was what i was trying to get
get away from
well the thing about and i'm not judging
like people like what they like okay but
it's like to me it seems very
narrow banned yeah
um
the reason that i got into goth and new
wave and post punk and stuff is that it
seemed very freewheeling right
um people are just kind of like
wait you like this and that okay that's
cool like nobody was like judging you
necessarily but age had a lot to do with
it yeah the biker women my age if i'm
playing they're gonna play the cure and
i'll put [ __ ] boys don't cry they
[ __ ] love it they know that they also
they know a lot of this [ __ ] that see
the chicks are like more open-minded
right
and i'm not and this is like um i found
this this is not right you know
universally true right but i found this
to be
true to an extent
dudes
in general tend to be a little more
narrow-minded yeah because they don't
want to come across as like oh does this
make me seem gay or yeah they have that
thing women don't have that no um they
just like what they like right uh and
they don't really make that much of a
to-do about it right so i've always
found that like dudes and their tastes
at least what they would admit to liking
were a lot more narrow my head
earlier on the show if you weren't here
i played a video that i made with meg at
the biker bar meg's uh 35
and she came up here from clearwater her
boyfriend is a
local harley builder
and uh
i made a video if you guys i'll play it
again if you guys didn't see it but
meg was 35 and she's in there playing
fly leaf
and [ __ ]
like eight like
90s and 2000s new metal that's that's
what she's listening to she you know so
it's not
social class or c in its age bracket has
more to do with it
okay then the bike scene
mary says i love daytona beach it does
actually have some nice things about it
the beach is beautiful
um if you want to go to a beach that is
actually brilliant although i will admit
that the ones on the west coast of
florida are nicer
um
but daytona you want to drive on the
beach you want to like drive your car on
the beach and like have a picnic and
stuff like that then daytona is going to
be like the place to go no need for me
too also says morrissey is big with the
latinas
yeah for whatever reason
uh yeah well drama yeah drama they
[ __ ] love morrissey now yeah yeah
mexico south america central america
they [ __ ] love more yeah you go um
there's a bunch of mexican
smiths and morrissey coverbank cover
bands that do it mexracy metroc being
is it max or say or mercy
i see maybe risky um are the best one i
think yeah but there's a bunch of
different ones yeah it's like cholo
version of [ __ ] morrissey
and with spanish lyrics and then it's
funny because
some mexicans will love morrissey but
they don't really understand the lyrics
of the culture that it comes from
like um they did a cover of um last of
the famous international playboys but
they translated it into like into
spanish
and um
which is a story about gangsters that's
about the craze it was about the cray
bros brothers yeah and the mexicans are
in those so you [ __ ] mexicans the
mexicans are [ __ ] cursing the
mexicans you [ __ ] mexican soul you
and your organized crime stopped talking
about gangsters and i had to jump in
there this is years back i had to jump
in the conversation like wait hold on
that is what the original song is about
it's about gangsters it's about the cray
brother yeah and it's some some ronnie
and reggie some non-english speakers are
reading into morrissey of what it is
morrissey's talking about that's what
happens he has a stylish well sinatra
crooner kind of a yeah but morrissey
loved crime and criminals
well
there is the romance behind crime there
is a subset it's not just morrissey um
you know i
i was married to a british person for uh
15 years and i went back and forth to
the uk
the uk has i don't know about nowadays
but back in the old days back in you
know the 80s and 90s
they had
there's some kind of they have this like
romanticism about not serial killers or
anything nobody likes those gangsters
but gangsters people that just like rob
banks or that just kind of like you know
get things over they there's some kind
of like romanticism about that like in
you know in some subculture so i kind of
feel like that morrissey like latched on
to that he does definitely have a
romanticized
vision of certain types of crime like
certain types of gangsters so he
you know last of the famous
international playboys is obviously
about the craze he names the craze in
the lyrics for christ's sake rajia and
he says their names in the words
so it's very clear that that's what he's
talking about yeah no more morrissey and
the smiths would uh go down well goes
down well in um
latino cultures
uh brazilian
mexican and everything in between there
because of the the drama yeah i get that
the the romance behind it uh
well that was what attracted me to it
yeah initially that's what they're
talking about the sentimentality
um
latin culture is very emotional and
sentimental
uh that's why i'm saying i could i could
go anywhere all throughout central and
south america and do fine because
everything is one-on-one and man-to-man
uh it is sentimentality a lot about
empathy as long as you don't but this
you these are romanesque cultures though
if you you you reap what you sow
if you betray people if you hurt people
you will be hurt it's eye for an eye
okay that's just but i i grew up like
like that so
i understand exactly what it is
loyalty it's about loyalty do not betray
people
you'll be okay
the thing is though is that
most of the time
if you enter any kind of agreement with
a central or south american you're
you're entering into it
voluntarily they won't force you into it
but if you go into this agreement
voluntarily you better [ __ ] uphold
your end of the bargain it's very
american in a way that's where the old
west was
it's uh it's natural to say a southerner
uh
honor based cultures not so much legal
legalistic cultures all right not this
is not really
a northeastern thing unless you're
talking about you know
the italian or the irish neighborhoods
outside boston then yeah you know
they're kind of like that too but it's
different well they're kind of like well
if you [ __ ] me over personally then i'm
going to take care of this [ __ ] that's
right i'm not going to get any greater
authority involved right exactly it's
it's man-to-man
you [ __ ] me over so i'm gonna have to
make you pay
nobody else is gonna see this it's
a gangster mentality yeah but that's
natural that's the way most people were
throughout the history of
civilization ancient rome was built on
those principles
mary says daytona you rent canvas rafts
and play in the waves all day also
correct motor scooters yeah um honestly
for the first
i want to say 20 like
almost 30 years of my life
i lived in daytona beach or like you
know around daytona beach when i was a
kid
my mom used to take us to the beach
every weekend
i hated it because i was like a a little
goth
kid even when i was like really young
and i was just kind of like i don't want
to tan so i used to like sit underneath
the pier so i wouldn't get any sun you
know what i mean yeah we would always
bring like a bucket of like kfc because
one of my uncles ran the franchise like
uh you know locally so we could get like
free chicken so we would get like the
kfc bucket
we go to the beach
my mom would just like lay out the sun
being like yeah she's like cooking and
stuff and i was just kind of like i'm
gonna go sit under here under the pier
so i don't get any sun
and um
i would sometimes go in the ocean but
i saw jaws
um
and i've had like little sharks
rub against my leg
in very shallow water yeah so
yeah that happens to you a few times
you're just like yeah no thank no thank
you i i would rather not now
raulito is uh fernandez is uh saying
that the arab people are still very
honor based he said yes i will attest to
this
um
i was in egypt for uh about about six
months and uh had a good time in egypt
and in israel and and sinai peninsula
had experienced good experience with
everybody there including the the
bedouins when i was on desert patrol
with the mfo
and a lot of my extended family my
grandfather
worked for uh grumman aerospace and was
sent by his company
to isfahan iran where he worked for the
shah of iran before he was overthrown
and then after that a lot of my uncles
who were from task force
160 special operations aviation group
they were helicopter pilots
um two of them and one of my outs
uh they're uh
in the middle east now like uh
and they uh they work as chopper pilots
one guy uh one of them is working for a
guy in
um oh
[ __ ]
one is saudi the other one is uh
man i can't remember the name of that
country
i'm drunks i don't remember
but uh as helicopter pies they make a
lot of money
they work for uh
i don't know if they're sultans but
they're on that level they're they're
semi-royal families
um
uh not what listen what is dubai
dubai one of my uncles works out of
dubai as a helicopter pilot executive
level helicopter pilot
and um
i have cousins
female cousins and [ __ ] that go there
all the time they're weather of shadora
they speak arabic and farsi
but so and my grandfather was
on my mother's side was um
um
you're right yeah yeah
good
[Laughter]
he was syrian he was half syrian he was
he was a syrian christian
so i guess he would probably
do a genetic test on me i would be
one quarter syrian
where if your grandfather was yeah he
was half syrian does that have been oh
okay so maybe an eighth one eighth yeah
yeah one eighth syrian christian am i
math incorrectly no you have four
grandparents
i know that so it makes you one quarter
right
well not necessarily
if he's half then that makes you one
quarter right one eighth one eighth yeah
that's what i said yeah yeah you're
right you're right i know right
his father was american
from connecticut
but his mother his mother was from syria
she was a syrian christian
so that would maybe one eighth
syrian
the rest of it is all irish and scottish
and german though
we need to do some damn probably some
native american we need to do a damn dna
test c
i have i did a native amer like a like a
a dna test on my mother's side yeah
uh which was
turkish yeah
via
europe okay because i was talking to
someone you know the you know the
the dude they found in turkey that was
like the
he was like he wasn't a mummy but he was
like you know what i mean the yeah
was this he wasn't it wasn't otzi the
iceman it was the other oopsie
yeah um
yeah but it was one they found in turkey
yeah uh my hapla group was the same as
that guys right
my dad's side of the family
is the native american right my mom's
side of the family was
turkish by a european european yeah
but um
i would uh
i i would like to see my dna test
because looking assad
he's a listener and he's in saudi arabia
he said well the the syrian christians
were western anyway
so i'm not sure how
middle eastern i would be in terms of
[ __ ] genetics
because evidently the syrian christians
were kind of more like
greeks at this point i kind of feel like
how much does it matter they're all
crazy i mean we're all kind of we're all
really kind of related right really it's
just kind of a a matter of degree
yeah you know what i'm saying right mary
says st augustine has great events this
weekend they have piles of oyster shells
honestly i love st augustine i did a
vacation in san augustine this past june
and i've been thinking about going back
although i would really like to do
like a week or two but i want to do it
in the winter time because it's too
[ __ ] hot to do in the summer
i mean i went in june last time and it
wasn't too bad but most time i was like
walking her all day going oh my god i'm
dying and i had like [ __ ]
you know it was like super super hot but
so i'd rather go in the winter time so
maybe we'll go like in january february
steve is talking about who what's the
best dna test to do that she'd be
interested to find out what hers were i
don't know i did one i did the one i did
was through um national geographic they
were actually doing a study
and they were it was for like
educational purposes they were trying to
like track like migration of populations
over the period
so
you could submit your [ __ ] to them and
they would tell you what haploid group
you were part of and yeah and where your
like ancestors came from what's up right
but i did it through that so i don't
know
i've heard like
good and bad things about [ __ ] like you
know 23andme and there's like a bunch of
different ones nowadays and some of them
i think you have to watch because some
of them i think are like [ __ ] they
will just kind of like send you
uh
just like some random like [ __ ] [ __ ]
that doesn't have anything to do with
your dna
yeah um so you do have to watch but it'd
probably be better to go with one of the
more
uh like kind of heavy-handed ones based
on my research t
prepare yourself because
most african americans who've been here
for more than a couple generations are
about 30 percent european
you say well i'm black well you look at
you you're black right but if you put
you against somebody from central africa
there's a big difference a lot of times
the way they look
in general african americans are about
30 european
so that's usually how it goes well
because even though you can't tell even
there's been a lot of like you know yeah
and obviously it's the us so everyone's
been humping everybody yeah it goes way
back so and then there's like a negative
aspect well that was slavery this and
that no no no
the blackest state well sometimes it was
there was some of that
but if you go back the blackest state
during the slave era was mississippi
it was 30 black didn't matter how big
the population was it's it tends to be
30 block
through most of mississippi's history
because half of those counties had
banned slavery through most of
mississippi's history
a lot of the black people i think more
than half of them were free people and
they were living right alongside white
uh white uh what do you call them um
subsistence farmers
there was a lot of interbreeding going
on
during that period
they had to pass laws to stop it
that
when you're passing laws to stop it that
means that it's happening
okay
so there was a lot of interbreeding
going on in the even in the so-called
slave days because there was a lot of
free black people during the slave days
just because you were black didn't mean
you were a slave in those periods in
that period
they had a lot of free people
for a lot of different reasons
some plantations just went broke in the
[ __ ] and the and the slave holder
they didn't call them owners they called
holders they had weird ways of [ __ ]
writing it out to kind of justify it so
it didn't sound so bad yeah because
they actually were trying to make this
look like they were helping people
well they would come from over there
we're helping them and and i'm just
holding them and you know we're taking
care of them yeah that was kind of what
they told me well yeah that was like the
narrative so some of them where it gets
kind of go broke or getting sick and
getting ready to die and they uh would
just free a lot of them
that's where a lot of it came from
that's where a lot of free people came
from and then they would
go on to have children with each other
but then there was weird [ __ ] going on
you'd have
a plantation owner who was crooked as
[ __ ]
who needed more labor and would hire
basically boba fett or some slave
catcher
kind of like a mercenary
to go to a goddamn free county that had
free blacks in it to go capture some
people and bring them back to a slave
county and make them work in a damn
uh [ __ ] plantation
now if you've seen that movie free state
of jones
jones county mississippi they're talking
about white people would go and
sometimes free them black people that
got re-enslaved too it wasn't
there's this [ __ ]
there's this [ __ ] thing in con in in
hollywood culture that everyone agreed
with slavery they didn't
slavery was
not popular especially with poor white
people for a lot of different reasons
and maybe it wasn't always you know well
we got to say these
religious people in general were like
this is wrong
poor people were like this is wrong
because it's making me broke
that had a lot to do with it because you
just couldn't compete with the
plantation
they would just
and the same thing was happening in
ancient rome
the rise of
populist uprisings and revolts which
overthrew the government and brought in
julius caesar was because the senators
had enslaved all these damn germans
and had them working on plantations
which
denied
combat veterans who'd been fighting a
[ __ ] war against them
what was the name of that what was the
name of that country they were fighting
in north africa
the thing was the peloponnesian was
carthage
they couldn't get their damn farm
because they were promised all this land
as retirement
if your civilization is based on slave
labor
you will never become a rich country it
just depresses the economy
and that was one of the problems of the
south
you just couldn't
make any money there as long as those
plantations existed
and
that was all the south could do because
as soon as you started any kind of damn
industrial activity
big companies up north would would use
[ __ ]
gangster tactics to [ __ ] destroy your
company
through uh you know and the railroads
did it the oil companies did it it was
very [ __ ]
uh uh it was a time of gangsterism
really they were called the robber
barons
and the robber barons kept the south
poor and agricultural
for a long time but they're not going to
tell you that in history of today
because they write the history
that south has always been oppressed
and a big business it more had more to
do with just very [ __ ] robber barons
well like the thing about it though is
that i kind of feel like when i was at
school
they kind of talked about the robber
barons
uh as though they were like the saviors
of america and [ __ ] like that but i do
kind of feel like now it's a big bag
they're at least teaching the reality
[ __ ] that it wasn't yeah they might have
done a few good things but
probably they did a lot of bad [ __ ] the
robber baron era was kind of like
america's version of the great elite the
great leap forward in china
yeah we became an industrial superpower
but on the backs of [ __ ] lots of poor
dead people yeah the the color didn't
matter
[ __ ] can i have some more tea
sir can i have some more porridge
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah it's
just kind of like
yeah it's the rockefellers and the [ __ ]
well like i said
in the 70s and 80s and i kind of feel
like back then they were still teaching
that
the r i don't even think i heard the
term robber baron until i was older they
didn't frame them that way when i was at
school they framed them as not
necessarily heroes
but they framed them in a way that's
like oh look we'd like this guy invented
this and this guy like had this big
company and
you know you know made this kind of like
a contribution to american society it
was very
um it was very glossed over yeah like
all of the people like we didn't hear
anything about railroad strikes or any
of that kind of stuff in when i was in
school at all so i kind of like feel
like that's good that people are
teaching that nowadays because that's
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up yeah um i don't
remember ever hearing about that in
school i didn't learn about it until
later so i was older
so they weren't teaching that in the 70s
yeah and then that's where i was yeah
and there's and then uh when they
they've really dumbed down why the south
had seceded
some people would say was because of
slavery other people said to to defend
slavery
then other people say no it was because
of states rights
it was both of those but that was only
half of it it actually had the the civil
war
had been going on for decades even
before that and it even went back into
the honky land of europe
it had a lot to do with [ __ ]
with ethnic [ __ ] conflict because the
south was mostly germans
irish and scottish the north was more
scandinavian
and
and british so
they hated each other back even in the
honky motherland so
it was all coming to the new country and
they're still like they're still
fighting in the new country over what
happened [ __ ] 200 years ago so it
goes further back than even america well
like i said everything's always more
complicated it's more complicated
so but you know there's only so much you
can teach like school kids right right
right but you should actually like kind
of teach them that not everything is
like black it wasn't black and white it
was mixed it was a mess at least a bunch
of [ __ ] give them like a taste of the
nuance
that was going on
right you go to the restroom um oh you
want some more yeah there's another
drink okay
uh
mary says most europeans have like one
or two percent neanderthal i got four
percent creepy that's not creepy
neanderthals were a were a proud race
and actually now everybody well most
white people i kind of feel like um have
a few like percentage of neanderthal in
there that's okay
like i said the neanderthals yeah they
didn't survive
but
they seem to be like pretty okay dudes
you know i'm okay with that i'm okay
with
and it's funny because even nowadays i
saw an actor in a movie the other day
i'm like oh look at that neanderthal
brow that you had so obviously some
people have like larger percentages than
others but that's okay that's okay and
uh i'm not i'm not shaming them because
neanderthals seemed like they had their
[ __ ] together they just
you know i don't think it was anything
to do with them being like quote-unquote
inferior
to homo sapiens uh i think it was just
it was a lot of different factors that
ended up with them like not
surviving you know i i just think it was
a lot of environmental factors that had
to uh go with it too so it wasn't just
that
um let's see if we're talking about
wineries northern california is the best
they don't really talk about the
carpetbaggers either i mean there's a
lot of stuff that's not covered i you
know it's been a long time since i've
been at school obviously
um
but i don't really remember in a lot of
my history classes i don't really
remember them getting into anything
super controversial i remember most of
the [ __ ]
was
very rah-rah
um you know aren't we the awesomest
like kind of like
there wasn't like a lot of
negativity brought into the american
myth
i feel like in the 70s and 80s when i
was going to school
um
and i feel like i didn't find out about
a lot of stuff [ __ ] i didn't even find
out that christopher columbus was a
piece of [ __ ]
until
a lot later because i kind of feel like
when i was in school as a kid they
taught you well christopher he he
discovered america and it was just like
this whole mythology that was built up
until you find out later on not exactly
that's that's not exactly what happened
and also he kind of sucked um you don't
really find that out until later on and
you have to kind of like search that
[ __ ] out on your own
so
in a way like i kind of like that
they're
i don't know i don't have kids nowadays
so i don't know what they're teaching
and like i don't know what the
curriculum is like i'm sure it's
different in every state but i think
it's better
to teach
more like what really happened you don't
have to go super into everything but
it's better to teach like a little bit
of nuance because nothing is ever
this is the good guy and this is the bad
guy there's always a lot of like nuance
going on and i think it's better that
like kids understand that like from an
early age because i got kind of i
remember being kind of upset
when
later on um you know i read about
christopher columbus i read about a lot
of stuff that had happened in american
history that they hadn't taught me in
history class thank you
and i was just kind of like why didn't i
ever get taught this it's just like this
isn't
you know and it's just kind of like i i
don't know i just kind of felt like
everybody sort of lied to me
just to make it seem like oh
everything's the best and we're not
going to talk about anything
controversial or
anything um
so you know i i think kids can handle it
i could have handled it
i you know i i just it makes me i don't
know it makes me sad i don't maybe
depending where you grew up i grew up in
daytona beach florida and they were
still very
christopher columbus discovered america
and this and that and the other thing
and it was just kind of like you know it
was all very like simplistic yeah and
all of like i said all of the robber
barons were
down absolutely not it's like oh look
what they built this and that and they
had all these kind of they're all
awesome like human beings and
they brought you know i don't remember
hearing anything negative really i don't
remember hearing about strikes i don't
remember hearing about any of the like
the bad [ __ ] that all the robber barons
were ruthless gangsters well sure they
just were but they never said that no
and they were very guilty about it
because in the end of their lives they
all knew each other they were all
friends
uh carnegie and [ __ ] uh
uh
i don't think so much the morgans i
think they were a little bit later
because as they got old and
getting ready to die off they got into a
race of giving away a competition of
giving away everything that they had we
got to give this all back to the people
oh well now we feel bad yeah now that
we're almost going to die
yeah anybody didn't feel bad earlier
deep down they were christians they were
afraid of going to hell the hell i'd do
that you know but but i will give it
this
they did build the infrastructure of the
union
like i said nothing's ever black or
white they never give you some good [ __ ]
they did yeah yeah um there's some
beautiful architecture there's some like
beautiful stuff that like that was
invented that wouldn't have happened
because of them
but they did a lot of really terrible
[ __ ] yeah they advanced technology
uh but this was at the cost of [ __ ]
there's a lot of human cost yeah but
here's the thing
a lot of the [ __ ] that they did was just
because they saw the opportunity they
took it it was advancement money
power
status for them
the the technological world did grow it
got better from their point of view yeah
people got hurt but you know what people
were everywhere and [ __ ] the thinking
of the time was well people don't live
long anyway [ __ ] them well
the thing about it is that look if
you've lived your entire life or even if
you've made like a [ __ ] ton of money so
much
so much that you don't have to worry
about anything ever again
you kind of go into this other
mindset
where
other cuban lives
don't matter to you at all you almost
kind of get into a thing where other
human lives they're just like ants to
you yeah pretty much so it's like well
if a couple thousand of them get crushed
yeah oh well gotta break a few eggs to
make an omelette like you don't think
about
that person and they have a family and a
whole extended like network of friends
and stuff that would
i mean you don't think about it like
that they don't yeah and hat and and
most of the robber barons were hood rats
themselves from europe
you're not talking about real
enlightened people
they were more like
witty ruthless and [ __ ] um
intelligent
they were uh just
and their way of looking at things was
like this
they see an opportunity
see i got a string i pull this string
and this will happen
if i pull this string my power will
double
well [ __ ] if
i pull the string of powers doubles but
these people get hurt
if i do but i don't know them so [ __ ] it
well not only that
other people can see this string if i
don't pull it they will so their power
will double well that's how they justify
oh they're like well if i don't do it i
don't do what somebody else does
there you go that's that's what they
were thinking that's what they're
thinking well i understand that i
understand like how they justified
themselves yeah it's still [ __ ] up
but you can justify that's the
justification though so it's a machine
driving that's how they feel that's how
they sleep at night because they think
to themselves i don't do it somebody
else somebody else will do it right and
those people will die anyway so i might
as well and make all the money right
that way i make the money instead of
that [ __ ] yeah because somebody's
going to make this money
yeah and that that's that's the way they
looked at it yeah
there was truth to it i know there was
truth to it it was like a mindless
machine running forward
i mean it's well it's i understand that
they think that it's just harder when
you're you know someone that's like me
that's like on the bottom right and it's
like when [ __ ] actually affects your
actual life
and you're like you know do they but you
have to understand they don't care
about they don't know you they don't
give a [ __ ] about you yeah i mean they
would just like if they could make some
money they would just like [ __ ] wipe
you out right now yeah they don't give a
[ __ ]
um what are jenny and tom drinking i am
drinking a screwdriver
that is just vodka skye vodka and orange
juice it is sky vodka and orange juice
i'm drinking el himador
uh uh
tequila tequila this is the uh reposado
which is kind of it's not silver and
it's not
anejo it's the it's in the middle with
uh
it's uh and it's a sunrise
[Music]
mike also says how come we're not
smoking tonight how long has it been
said you've been here i haven't smoked
in forever we haven't smoked in years
and years and years yeah quit smoking we
quit smoking and we quit vaping
because i kind of feel like i still get
comments nowadays about the vaping yeah
from the old shows because remember you
used to because remember we used to uh
before we were even on camera
but it was just audio was like a
slideshow okay and you would be on there
like
[Laughter]
tammy's came up with a good one what
about old west outlaws
i know all about them i mean we did do a
ghost of the old west and that one was
really fun yeah i can do all kinds of
old west outlaws know all about them and
the weapons that they used the tactics
and they were good they were very good
some of them were real good wild bill
was one of the best ones [ __ ]
was a badass shot a great trick shot
made a lot of money uh doing uh doing
traveling old west shows later on dude
could shoot
it was just another era they could shoot
they were real good
six rounds that was it and a [ __ ]
revolver that was very slow to reload
they could hit if they could see it they
could hit and they could shoot with two
different hands and hit different
targets at the same time
you could throw some up in front and
snap shoot it and hit it they were very
good didn't use sights it was all just
by feel muscle memory
he wow bill was deadly
and it wasn't and he was a celebrity and
it wasn't [ __ ]
law enforcement agents you know would
deputize him and help him go out and do
things you know it's just like look
now that you're in town like i'm having
a problem with this dude uh let me
deputize you i'll give you 200 bucks to
help me arrest this guy if i could need
you to back me up and then you'd be put
just put his drink down and put the
cards down yeah okay what day
all right give me
yeah
and um well that it was the gig economy
yeah
before they called it and then it was a
small before you were driving for uber
you would go and help cops round up
outlaws and it was a small scene and you
had uh uh you had guys writing
pulp novels
and they were from uh from new england
they would go down into the west and
write pulp novels about these guys and
try to sell them over in [ __ ] new
york and boston
uh a good uh that's why you remember
them more from the pulp novels that was
so so it's more like the social media of
this time right then it was maybe the
actual [ __ ] that happened but like i
said that's kind of like right
humans are we like stories yeah um we're
not really interested in what really
happened we just want like a really good
story a good a good movie on this that
was fairly accurate and i can [ __ ]
attest to every pretty much everything
that's said in this
who's been in [ __ ] dangerous
situations that are not armed conflicts
where people got killed it was um
uh what was the name what was the name
of that [ __ ] um the unforgiven
watch it was just unforgiving
unforgivable
yeah yeah
that was a that was awesome and that's a
pretty accurate portrayal of the old
west
it even has the writer in there
and then the duck or the duke you know
because you had fakes you also had fake
gun fighters
it was it was the same [ __ ] thing
like i said humans are not that
different it's just um all that's
different is like the technology of the
time
if you knew what you were doing you
could work whatever the cutting edge
technology was t if you haven't seen
unforgiven see i'm forgiven she's asked
about the donner party did we do a show
about the documentary on it did a show
on it i think we did a show i'm pretty
sure i can't believe we did a show on
cannibalism yeah
i remember doing a show about the
donovan i don't i don't think it was
just about the donner party i think we
talked about the donner party and what
maybe one other case that was like old
west mike says i love you jello reviews
jenny
thank you
actually in june
i'm thinking about doing all giallo
movies
for june yeah
it's gonna be giallo june
like april and may i'm just gonna do
like whatever because there's a lot of
movies that i have to catch up on
um
of just
you know whatever subgenre but i want to
get back to doing glo so i thought well
giallo june that kind of sounds good so
i'm gonna do all jealous movies for june
so just a heads up on that but i did do
trauma
which is going up
tomorrow unless you're a patreon which
case you've already seen it
but i'm putting it up tomorrow that's
sort of a giallo that was a forgotten
dario argento movie
and uh it has some um
interesting uh kind of [ __ ] but i don't
know dario argento
put his daughter asia into a lot of his
movies
trauma was the first one where he did
that and she was still
i kind of feel like technically she was
still a minor i think she was 17 when
this was shot she's supposed to be 16 in
the movie she might have been 18 i'm not
entirely sure
but the fact that like she's showing her
boobies and there was like this all i
don't know there's like a weird dynamic
between those two they're asking how the
gardens going been getting a lot of
spinach out of the garden making pizzas
with it he made me pizza and it had
spinach on it from the garden it was
delicious yeah
it was a white pizza with spinach and
chicken canned chicken i can get canned
chicken to the general store for only
like a dollar fifty so i'm like yeah i'm
gonna put this on going down to gender
because pizza topping out of that [ __ ]
then old west yeah
and then um
uh
potatoes are coming
i should be able to yield enough
potatoes to supply a whole month's worth
of potatoes each month we'll we'll see i
got to get it right i mean potatoes are
good to have yeah onions broccoli
broccoli comes pretty regularly and then
the leaves off the broccoli i'm gonna
try to make an indian thing like sog you
know like like sog yeah
maybe like saag paneer or palik paneer
with the chicken
or some or polik sog something like that
i forgot what it was called pillock yeah
would be like a green creamy
because there's a lot of stuff that
comes out of there that
you can eat it
but normally the market would probably
throw it away like when have you bought
when have you bought cauliflower leaves
because there's leaves right yeah
they're edible
but
people don't buy those
but people didn't used to buy chicken
wings not really that's what i mean if
you know what to do with it do with them
right you can make something out
uh tomatoes but man i'm [ __ ] worried
about tomatoes there's so many produce
predators with tomatoes i don't know if
tomatoes will come i mean you gotta
watch where we live it's a little bit
rural right so we have a lot of [ __ ]
no little animals
out here
that you can't blame them they're like
hey free [ __ ]
it's like going to the fast food
restaurant so you know put a bunch i'm
gonna i'll take a video and we'll put it
up on the thing [ __ ] i got a whole
bunch of smart dudes got a whole bunch
of bushes around the perimeter they're
very small right now they're small right
now but they'll grow into hedges that'll
be like we wanted like a privacy hedge
right
around because we have like a big lot
but it's open once that's done
the neighbors and the [ __ ] hoa will
not be able to see
my back lot okay which is it's big back
lot
man i if i wanted to i could put a
chicken coop out there or i could put
[ __ ] rabbits out there even though
man slaughtering rabbits have hurt my
feelings please don't
i could kill chickens no problem
i could [ __ ] i could keep chickens
out there just to have eggs
i would rather just have egg chickens
right i mean if we had egg chickens i
could the thing is i don't want you like
killing chickens or rabbits and i don't
want to watch that come on
i know i killed chicken i can kill
chickens no problem but there's
something about rabbits they're too
close to a cat that's what i mean yeah
that'd be like killing a pookie you're
right yeah they're too close to a cat
and my friend angel says i'm being there
angel's this goth girl that we know
she's been over here and she's gonna say
i'm keep breathing rabbits when i get
ready i'll give you [ __ ] several
rabbits a week we'll trade this and that
that's where start trading food and it
says how do you kill those rabbits and
he goes i got this [ __ ] piece of
woods like a v i put their heads in like
that pull like that embrace her [ __ ]
hand
and she's i'm like
i used
this is you know you don't feel nothing
i don't eat rabbits i don't eat rabbits
i'm like
i could cut his head off maybe with a
cleaver but you just it's just yeah it
doesn't matter it just knocks them out
no i couldn't do that i'm like those are
kind of cute though
you know
i mean i can kill chickens i just
[ __ ] bam they're just chickens you
know what i mean but you know but if i
had to i would but like a rabbit
i don't eat rabbit either i killed it
let me show you guys i i'll kill deer i
even got pictures to prove that i killed
deer
all right
nobody wants to see that come on no i
got i got pictures of my mike says
stendall syndrome is ozzier argento's
best performance great film i agree
um a lot of people said that daario kind
of lost it after opera maybe 1987
but not true stendle syndrome is good
some people like sleepless although i
haven't seen it in a while uh but i
really like stendhal syndrome although
it's really weird how he put asia
argento in there and like she got
brutally raped in there uh you know
multiple times which is [ __ ] up that's
me as a kid
uh with one of my dear kills killed that
with a [ __ ] 50 caliber muzzle loader
that was out in mississippi
i killed i killed deer and you can't eat
them but i don't know if i can bust
their head off of down rabbit
rabbits are so [ __ ] they're kind of
cute you know
like i said i had a pet rabbit yeah his
name was scooter
some people asked about my mom i'm going
to show you guys a picture of my mom
that's tom's mom
that's a very old very open
there
yeah okay
tila says apparently bunnies and cats
can be raised together and have fun yeah
they can everything i mean
like i said i had a pet rabbit when i
was younger or somebody yeah being too
small and too cute and just they're so
cute and fuzzy like they're a little
[ __ ] yeah it's too much like a cat
too much like a cat nope
i really have to be [ __ ] desperate
yeah i'd really have to be desperate i
don't like killing cute animals for the
[ __ ] i don't even like killing ugly and
so well like i said earlier
i was watching kingdom of the spiders
and i was getting upset at them killing
tarantulas because i'm sure they did for
them and i was like but they're so big
and they're fuzzy and it's like
they're kind of cute knock it off what
are you doing you're stepping on them
and stuff it's like oh
i was getting kind of upset and like i
couldn't like watch it so tom doesn't
like spiders so he thinks that's funny
but honestly
mike says tom was a badass back in the
day i still am a badass you're talking
i'm better ass now than i ever was i
only weighed about 130 back in those
days bro
i could be i could go back and beat my
18 year old self up
oh wait would you it's not as pretty
would you do that not as pretty as it
was but if i invented a time machine
would you go back and beat my old cell
phone and beat your old self yeah yeah
for youtube for me being a dumbass back
then
but i kind of well i kind of feel like
everybody that's older yeah you look
back at yourself you're dumb ass i mean
i don't do that though i don't think i
was stupid back in the old days although
the weird thing about it is that
um
that's right cats and raccoons also get
together yeah they do
beijing loves raccoons loves raccoons
yeah she tried to [ __ ] the raccoons like
four of them showed up
i love you [ __ ] i love all of you
adopt me yeah
she is trying to [ __ ] i am also a
raccoon yeah she was trying to surrender
to the raccoons are like what is this
thing
you have a puppy tail i have a piece
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're both kind of
stripey we're i'm kind of
yeah beige was trying to [ __ ] get
laid she totally was she was trying to
like get herself adopted into into the
into the record into the raccoon
it was a raccoon family unit yeah i i
don't know what that was about
but she was sexual i could tell it by
her body language
she's like you guys are so cute
[Laughter]
come get some of this
beijing is so weird yeah she got fixed a
long time ago but she still is very
i mean beijing she's older she's what
how old is she 12 or 13 yeah she's old
um
she's very much a princess yeah she's
very much princess
yeah maybe i'll put some chickens out
there once those hedges grow up we'll
see there's chickens and there's cows
over there and everything i might buy a
cow
i got a [ __ ] freezer coming up bought
a freezer and the [ __ ] from through
amazon and it never showed up
it never showed up so
i [ __ ] told him i says this [ __ ]
never showed up it said it arrived here
and never they gave me my money back so
amazon's lying i bought another freezer
we'll see if that one shows up because
well they said they delivered it but i
think well [ __ ] i'm trying to order off
amazon never shows up i think they
delivered it to a neighbor's house and
the neighbor was like hey free freezer i
don't think they did maybe i don't think
it ever came because they gave the money
back instantly and i have um a bunch of
[ __ ] that didn't show up
my [ __ ] uh uh throat mic and
everything from [ __ ] radios never
showed up it said it did i'm asking for
a refund haven't got it
[ __ ] glass vials for [ __ ] test
test and other kind of [ __ ] that i'm
gonna make later on never showed up
anything from china is not showing up
amazon's lying about what's in your
house
recently these supply these supply lines
aren't working
they're telling you they're working
they're not working
but they gave me my money back
well i mean this is said about it
and i go down here and i go down here
and [ __ ] they're out of stock of
everything at these [ __ ] stores
the shells will be full
but it's the same thing over and over
again the selection isn't there there's
no lemon cookies
where my [ __ ] lemon cookies where's
my [ __ ] where's my where's my [ __ ]
peanut butter cookies
even even at even at publix i went in
there to go look for [ __ ] lemon
sunshine cookies
they didn't have it they have
i've been in public they're extinct
they're extended and i'm looking and
then i wanted this as well i'm gonna get
some of that [ __ ] public soda diet
soda diet soda was gone
they're making it look like [ __ ]
their soda there they'll just take some
[ __ ] so to make and fill up yeah i
know they're done
they're trying to pad it and they're
trying to make it look like they have a
selection there's no selection there i
haven't told you that i've been
shielding you from that the selection is
going away
now i know the selection's going away
you're not sure like i've been there
it's okay
yeah
he thinks he's shielding me shielding
her from the truth
okay
like i can't find things out on my own
if you can't find the [ __ ] thank you
that's very paternalistic
um
that's right the illuminati in china
have [ __ ] plotted to stop getting the
lemon cookies that's right ben
thomas not allowed to have lemon cookies
cookies about to disappear now lemon
cookies are the best
vanilla vanilla cookies are second down
here those are still pretty good
how are you going to live without lemon
cookies
i can live without lemon cookies
i can live i mean they're good
yeah
but if somebody told me i couldn't have
them
how long we've been streaming i don't
know three hours okay
john gore says food of the gods is
pretty upsetting when they're blasting
real rats yeah i kind of feel like
i thought that the whole animal cruelty
laws i thought that came about in the
70s did it not
i think probably certain animals you can
kill
rats because i kind of feel like i was
re-watching kingdom of the spiders like
the rift tracks from last night and i
was like
they're killing like actual tarantulas
like they're running them over and like
stepping on them and stuff and i was
like you would not get away with that
now um and rightfully you shouldn't be
[ __ ] doing that for just for a movie
just for a movie don't like [ __ ] kill
animals for a movie jesus christ no they
were blasting rats with 22s ah they're
just rats yeah there's more of them
whatever they're they're vermin in
the 70s so they're like yeah shoot the
rats
but what's funny is rats are like
actually quite intelligent well here's
the here's the reason why you shouldn't
be doing that this is not a real rat
infestation these are rats that were
purchased on the commercial market
placed into this location
very different from you're at your farm
there's a rat infestation and you're
going to bring the dogs in and okay
these rats yeah that's a different
situation this is not going to be that
you're shooting yeah this is a movie
right it's not a setup yeah these are
not actual rats that are invading right
[ __ ] they're eating all the stuff out of
your silo it's not nature this is an
unnatural situation so don't don't kill
rats
because what you end up what it ends up
being is that you're killing rats for
the entertainment of the crowd
not cool and nowadays everybody's just
like [ __ ] did you just kill a real rat
[ __ ] you right and that's what i'm
thinking if you want to see the real
thing
you go on youtube and you can watch
trained dogs
whole teams of trained dogs that'll go
to somebody's farm to [ __ ] get rid of
a rat infestation and they are badasses
they will [ __ ] hunt down hundreds of
rats
bite them kill them and then bring them
back to master and drop them in a damn
bucket and they'll have buckets of
[ __ ] dead rats
and then they put them in the back of
the damn truck and and they can wipe out
an entire rat infestation on a [ __ ]
on a um
on a farm in a few hours without any
insecticides
totally natural
now what do you do with all that biomass
of all those rats
i would probably make fertilizer out of
them i mean you would have to do
something right i wouldn't waste it
actually
i try to
chop them up and throw them in a [ __ ]
pond and let the catfish get them and
then you go eat the catfish later i'd do
something like that with them
but uh you don't want to waste biomass
let some eat that
you know that's i mean i have a hard
time even though i still eat meat i have
a hard time like watching yeah animals
killed for the entertainment like just
not a movie yeah from a movie yeah not
for a movie [ __ ]
john gore says cats and heat are
hilarious yeah they are we have a video
yeah of pookie when she was still little
and she went into her first heat
it was um we had already made an
appointment for her to get fixed yeah
but uh a week or two before the
appointment
she went into heat
and
she wasn't very old she was only like
what eight months yeah not even a year
not even a year old
and i took a video of it because oh i
felt so bad for her i called it kitty
pawn far yeah i don't know if i ever
posted it or not out of it oh my god she
was like she kept like screeching down
like on the kitchen floor and she'd
stick her butt up in there and she was
going
get it get it get it and i was just kind
of like oh my god look at her [ __ ] it
was terrible i felt so bad but it was
like so funny beige was worse even when
i got
before i got her fixed and before i knew
you well yeah because before yeah
because i i don't know if you guys know
but he got he's had beijing since a
couple years before him yeah yeah like i
when i met you like beijing was older
yeah i went through two heats with
[ __ ] beijing and after that second
one i had to have her fixed
[ __ ] she drive me [ __ ] crazy
wouldn't leave me alone
yeah she's like you're the ballerina
you're the only male thing in this area
please you know so she's like sticking
her butt up yeah yeah
couldn't go anywhere she'd follow you
around [ __ ] grab you by your feet
your shoes and [ __ ]
oh don't go
come on yeah yeah meet my needs yeah oh
[ __ ] funny they don't know any better
that's what's kind of sad well that's
what like kind of broke my heart about
pookie because she was still
so small she was still like a kitten she
wasn't even a year old i think she was
like eight months old animals know
gender though they know male from female
in in other species they know
it was just it was hilarious like the
way she learned she was just like on the
kitchen floor and she was like
and like her little butt and then i was
like oh my god look at this
i was like we have to get her to the vet
like right now
like i said we'd already made the
appointment we just said she hadn't gone
yet
she's been a lot more chill
tammy says jenny lives such a sheltered
life right yeah yeah well it's because
i'm protecting you that's what you
talking about he's protecting me
protecting you from from what's missing
at the damn [ __ ] publix
at the [ __ ] dollar general i've been
to the dollar general a lot of shit's
missing and the publix yeah um would did
beijing freak out if you try to put on
camera no she would ignore it
no she's like too cool for anything
anything yeah she's beijing's thing
uh pookie is just kind of like hey what
are you doing what are you doing yeah
beijing is like [ __ ] you yeah did you
see
that did you i don't even go here did
you see beijing when we when we when i
got a cut like a lion and she had the
whole [ __ ] i played that earlier we
posted that earlier that was a couple
years ago yeah just [ __ ]
she just got boots on and a [ __ ] mane
and a little [ __ ] round pom-pom on
youtube
and a [ __ ] bow on her head
it cost 80 bucks to get her cut she
liked the bow though i was surprised
because normally she doesn't like
anything
impeding her
whatever right
i mean beijing
that's what i mean when people that that
cut lasted a long time it was it was 80.
people talk about cats and it's like
well cats have different personalities
yeah beijing and pookie are completely
different yeah beijing is very much a
princess and she is very much too cool
for this [ __ ]
um she does not want you to know that
she gives a crap about anything she's
very like i'm
i don't even know like why i'm over here
cutter cut her like that because she um
had a fever and was [ __ ] sweating so
she she got sick so she looked real hot
so i had her hair cut off because she
was [ __ ] so furry to give her some
relief she has very a lot of hair yeah
too much hair she has a lot and she felt
better but i could i kind of think that
she felt embarrassed
i think she felt like she was she seemed
she was kind of like shy she was acting
a little weird the whole time after that
happened i don't have any clothes on
well because
it was probably well it probably didn't
help that we were just kind of like a
big deal about laughing look at you and
i told her i was like we're not laughing
at you i promise and she was just like
i'm over it's like [ __ ] y'all
yeah
why don't you do this where are my
clothes why'd you do this to me
so her hair is grown back nowadays yeah
but now that we've been at this house
she took over the downstairs yeah
um she will try to encroach upstairs
yeah but there's a whole we've talked
about this before there's a whole um
[Music]
kind of like conflict
because pookie
owns the upstairs yeah
beijing owns the downstairs
and the staircase is like
the neutral zone yeah but so there's a
lot of like so pookie sometimes i'll get
up in the middle of the night to go to
the bathroom and pookie is
sleeping perched across the top of the
staircase like this
she's
thinking if if beijing comes up the
stairs she wants to be right there to
smack her yeah
it's just it's hilarious the two of them
they're saying that you can order lemon
cookies online all right you have to
understand some
in the south we grew up with a company
called sunshine and i can't find
sunshine anymore it might be gone they
might be out of business it was the
little debbie of cookies
all right
the little tag on the top it was a lemon
tag with a little fat man dressed up as
a [ __ ] chef and say sunshine all
right i'm the fat sunshine little fat
yeah he says little fat man
chef's outfit
well they had a one called lemon drop
cookies
and they were kind of like they came in
a bag or a box with a bag inside
it was a green box yeah i remember that
they were like nilla wafers round
and they had chips in them but instead
of chocolate chips they were lemon
flavored chips and they were rolled in
[ __ ] powdered sugar so it was kind of
like what we call here in the south of
cocoon
but a cocoon was
had um
um
i mean pecans it was butter and pecan
butter pecan cocoon cookie they were
like that but they were
they were lemon
they were a butter cookie with lemon
chips in them rolled and powdered sugar
it was diabetes just waiting to [ __ ]
happen
make you fat as [ __ ]
they were great
well not if you just say it one right
so i was looking for those i couldn't
find them
i found
kind of like hydrox cookies which would
be like a like a like a oreo cookie
where you got a
which is funny those are good too well
let me just say
filling with the [ __ ] vanilla cookies
on the outside they had them here they
were great but they did they stopped
bringing them it's a lemon cookie
apocalypse
people don't think that hydrox yeah were
ripped off of oreos no but hydrox came
first they were the first ones oreos
were i will admit that oreos are better
than hydraulics right but hydroxy
originals right so oreos hydraulics
although if you did it better
kudos
yeah y'all yankees don't understand that
[ __ ] hydrox was the original and it was
they were ghetto [ __ ] it's a terrible
name it sounds like it sounds like a
drug for like some [ __ ] sexual that
was probably some high-tech [ __ ] back in
the 30s when it came out they were the
prototype
oreo
oreo was an improved hydrox
i am not i will say right here maybe
this is controversial i'm not a huge fan
of oreos if i'm going to if i'm going to
eat oreos they got to be double stuffs i
don't like the single stuff i like the
real
i don't like the chocolate cookie action
as much
all that [ __ ] i'm learning vanilla
cookies all that [ __ ] y'all do all that
[ __ ] y'all do [ __ ] going to damn
dairy queen and making these blizzards
and [ __ ]
we invented that okay that was [ __ ]
okay now like oreos
blizzards and stuff that's good that's
right that's southerners
[ __ ] white and black
we made that [ __ ] ourselves we go and
get some [ __ ] ice cream and crush up
oreo cookies or anything
m m's and put it in the ice cream and
[ __ ] store it like that
wheat and if you had to add a little bit
of milk to [ __ ]
loosen it up some
then or
blender in a blender you could do it
like that too because we have butters
but that's a southern thing y'all stole
it from us
y'all stole it gotta say though
and [ __ ] there was all kinds of [ __ ]
we would do eminem's
cookies
like
oreo cookies well
chocolate chip cookies dairy queen with
their blizzards blizzard right the best
ones i think are not the oreo ones i
think the best numbers are snickers yeah
and heath bar he bar and what we did was
toffee we did those two
you took your bars and you froze them
first
and then once they were frozen you hit
them with a hammer to shatter them
and then you put those in ice cream and
mix it up stickers are better frozen
anyway yeah
um i'm just gonna say that right now
yeah and honestly i kind of like that
some convenience stores i don't know
about now but some convenience stores
for a time
would sell snickers out of the freezer
section which i was a big fan of yeah uh
because that's way better they're good
like just at room temperature another
time we have homemade ice cream and
homemade snickers okay
we made homemade ice cream a lot
the thing is
even back in the 70s and the 80s you
could buy ice cream cheaper than you
could make it even back then remember
that
yeah it was more expensive well the only
ice cream we usually made was peach
peach peach okay because that was
seasonal you couldn't get it and my
grandma and my dad were super into pizza
i wasn't a big fan but um they loved
peach ice cream so they
you could only get it during the summer
right peaches
they would just make it and you can find
peaches just laying out laying out in
the grass underneath the trees
so you to make peach ice cream
and real southern peach ice cream was
[ __ ] fantastic you got to check the
[ __ ] for worms though because some of
that [ __ ] was too found off the ground
yeah you don't want a worm ice cream so
you got to cook it all up you got to cut
it and make sure that nothing got into
it and then wash it and
put it in the ice cream maker
you had the rock salt on the outside the
cream the sugar yeah remember i did like
that and then you'd take the [ __ ]
peaches and put them in there oh man
chip is so good i mean we made vanilla a
few times too because i bitched but
mostly peanut butter in there mostly
they made peanut butter ice cream inside
the vanilla ice cream did that the this
is all kind of stuff see that's one
thing that i wish that we had done but
we had never you didn't do the peanut
butter i don't think we did the peanut
butter we mostly just did vanilla or
mostly it was peach because like i said
it was my grandma's ice cream maker
yeah and my dad and they were super into
peach old school southerners and like i
said you couldn't get it it was a
seasonal thing old school southern homes
had [ __ ] more peanut butter than you
that you could ever eat i mean you could
get jars of peanut butter that were that
big around that tall for only a couple
dollars
so it was a cooking ingredient you could
just
scoop out a couple cups of peanut butter
and throw it into a damn vanilla ice
cream mix and it would sit there in a
minute it would come out and like that
sounds good
man it was so good
it was [ __ ] really good
mike says peach ice cream no yeah i'm
not i'm not a big fan of fruity ice
cream
i don't hate it it wasn't fruity though
it was creamy it's just not my favorite
yeah um and peach is not really my
favorite fruit flavor gotta say if i'm
gonna eat ice cream
i would rather it be
like a more like bitter flavor i like uh
chocolate or coffee i like vanilla
actually but it has to have something in
it yeah you know what i mean i like
cookie dough or nuts or yeah mint
chocolate chip or something it has to
have like some kind of texture i don't
really like a lot of fruit i don't like
fruity ice cream i don't like sherbet i
don't like anything like that i like all
that i love it all i know you do but i
don't i mean i don't hate it i'll eat it
i'm not saying that but i'm talking
about [ __ ] peanut butter cheesecake
and all that stuff
now
i must admit you know when i was up in
michigan graham knows
be up there go to my friend steve's
house and his mom was back when i was in
high school
his mom would make candy bars by the
sheet pan
she would make oh henry bars man those
[ __ ] were good oh yeah my mom used to
do that oh henry bar by the sheet pants
i [ __ ] tear them things like the home
version yeah thank you thank you john
robertson thank you hey guys i had to
tune in to tom's show and him talking
about the south i was raised by my great
grandparents and i heavily understand
what you're talking about uh tom i
wanted your opinion on the sith from
star wars okay
from star wars oh okay clarify about
what kind of opinion you're talking
about
well you just like just give your okay
all right
here we go
maybe star wars
actually came from joseph camp the story
behind charlotte
behind star wars came from joseph
campbell
lucas listens to campbell a lot
and campbell
got a lot of that stuff from buddhism
and uh
there's a lot of truth to what they were
saying in the old star wars stuff
um
it also mixes in with europeans that
read about star wars and tried to bring
that person you read about your it mixes
in with what europeans were reading
about buddhism and they brought it into
the world that's the thing joseph
campbell kind of like codified a lot of
the things that worked in stories yeah
that made stories long-lasting yeah he
was trying to like um break down what
elements of it were
you know uh that resonated with people
right so there's a mythological truth
you say well what is a mythological
truth there's a lot of true lessons in
mythology
now
europeans brought
buddhism
into the european sphere in the 1800s
that would have been
arthur
schopenhauer and friedrich nietzsche
later on
and uh
that's what you're talking about when
you're talking about the sith
this
if you
look at what friedrich nietzsche is
talking about when he's talking about
going beyond the concepts of good and
evil
if you have some dumb [ __ ] who's
just evil
not much happens to him he gets killed
he gets into a fight he gets killed and
he dies
or he goes into prison
and this even goes back to justice
in either even the schopenhauer
but it's very different if you take a
talented [ __ ] and immerse him
into
pain and turmoil and he kind of becomes
evil
then what you end up with is kind of
like a extremely gifted evil that is a
very effective and that's what they're
talking about with with the with the
sith
it's internal conflict
now what happens when this person
has
paranormal abilities
in other words this person is a psychic
what happens then
you now have
a very gifted
[ __ ] psychopath who's gone beyond
good and evil who's very intelligent
and he has psychic abilities that's what
a seth is that's what he said this if
that really existed we'd be in big
trouble it does exist
it does exist but it doesn't exist as
far as i know
to the level of what they're showing you
in those movies that's what i mean
the
the most extreme version of that would
be kind of like what you see in
poltergeist cases
but
as far as i know they can't control it
i can't control what moves jenny's seen
it
she's seen it
it's not something that can be
controlled but if it exists it seems
predicated upon you not being conscious
you can't be conscious of what you're
because there's something having to do
with the unconscious kind of like what
they're talking about with carl young
i mean the fact that you're conscious of
it kind of like [ __ ] spoil it sure
thinking about it foils it because
conscious thoughts we shouldn't do it if
that is a fail safe i'm glad that you're
right because otherwise we would be so
big humans whatever it is humans are not
really built
to use that
aliens may maybe
hire
creatures that are more highly evolved
might be like that
i'm i'm saying that for real based on
what i've seen now intellectuals are
gonna say this motherfucker's crazy i'm
not an intellectual i'm i have instincts
and
experiences
being intellectual can stop that kind of
stuff and it's not supernatural it's
something having to do
with quantum physics
you want to look at
you want to look at uh uh uh
that guy who's into anesthesia [ __ ] man
what's his name jordan yeah stewart
hammer off and uh
roger penrose the guy who has the uh
the hey i'm drunk and i can't tell you
yeah you know
[Laughter]
hammer off and penrose and hammer off
and penrose have come out with new
videos in the past couple years listen
to them i listened to one more recently
and i was like yeah okay and in the end
hammer off is like and this stuff what
i'm talking about might explain certain
things that people call paranormal
phenomena
it's not it is paranormal but it's not
supernatural
it's quantum let's do quantum physics
it's just not going to be as theatrical
as you see in star wars and it's not
going to be as controllable
it's going to be more along the lines of
what you see in
uh uh
[ __ ] this house is haunted by
and uh math mountain poultry guys it's
gonna it's gonna be weird phenomenon
that happened randomly rspk recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis
here's the thing
if
l ron hubbard believed this what i just
told you he was a crackpot though
a total crackpot he thought you could
train somebody to do this jedi style you
can't
but one of his dudes who was like one of
his main [ __ ] right-hand man
accountants was having [ __ ]
out-of-body experiences and and had
these experiences he joined scientology
and it [ __ ] it foiled all of his
abilities to do it
it's something very naturalistic i'm
trying to remember what his name was he
was the only black guy in scientology
and he had some parents probably was
actually yeah he was the only black guy
in scientology and l ron hubbard knew
him and put him in charge of all the
finances and all the higher stuff i'm
trying to remember what his name is you
can find him on youtube
he did whole
um
interviews and talked about
how turned out scientology was all full
of [ __ ] and that it actually
and that it you don't say it yeah and it
actually prevents you from having these
experiences it doesn't promote them
because
thinking about it too much
trying to have some kind of [ __ ]
organized training program trying to
force things
is that that's not how the human mind
works that's not a human consciousness
words it's a very natural process
that happens when you least expect
expect it a lot of it kind of
semi dream states altered consciousness
states
extreme
emotional states can can kind of if you
allow it can kind of allow it to happen
but you won't be able to control the
phenomenon it's under control of your
unconscious mind
like a jungian
mind the dark side in my case it was the
dark side
so i'm kind of scared of it
hugo says have you have you guys seen
what the bleep do we know if so what are
your thoughts um
that
movie
is pretty much [ __ ] from top to
bottom
[ __ ] from top to bottom
um it sounds good
but
i don't know i watched it a while back
and i was just kind of like you guys
sound like you're saying something like
cool and important and everything but
you're not actually saying anything that
means anything he's talking about
pistachio cookies from trader joe's
matt may hearing about trader joe's do
we have a we don't have to we have the
other one no we have trader joe's
um there's a trader joe's in
i think there's one in lake mary like
mary we gotta check it out we'll go
later because there's trader joe's and
what's the other one
you have aldi's and then the other one
trader joe's and then the other one
remember
well there's world market
i thought trader joe's had two different
forms
i'm not real sure kind of like aldi has
two different forms there's two
different holidays no but yeah but
there's only aldi the aldi that we have
yeah is the only aldi that exists in the
u.s okay the only other aldi is like
europe okay because there's two
different now isn't there two different
forms of trader joe
i don't know i thought there was but
trader joe's is pretty like what do we
have a trader joe we have trader joe's
right yeah it's in i'm pretty sure it's
in like mary okay i passed it
but the thing with trader joe's is that
it's uh very high quality products they
have their own store brands and they're
good
and the prices are pretty good
trader joe's is good john robertson is
asking me if i have any peter cushing
movie recommendations okay
i have to say peter cushing
i love him in any movie
okay
any movie that he's in is good
but um honestly i have to say that any
movie that he's in with christopher lee
um that's gonna go right to the top of
the list because i really liked their
interactions with one another so i
really liked like horror express for
example because they were both in it
um i
reviewed one recently
uh that he was in that peter cushing was
in but not christopher lee
which was the one with uh called the
beast must die which was
the one with the werewolf break he's not
in it a lot
but
you know i was kind of into that anyone
where he kind of plays
i don't know like what was that one that
uh [ __ ] man i'm kind of like drunk and i
can't like remember right now
but the one that he was in was
christopher lee and he played the thing
and
he played the scientist and christopher
lee was like the guy that had the
skeleton i'll take it like in a minute
but yeah
i mean he was really good i kind of feel
like he played a lot of like [ __ ]
doctor kind of characters and i was like
into that too yeah horror express that's
i mean that's a really good one but
you know he was good in a lot of um
there were a lot of anthologies too he
was a lot of in in a lot of uh amicus
ones
and
uh
you know tales from the crypt was he in
that one
house of drip blood
was that another one
i can't remember now but he was in a lot
of like amicus ones and those are all
good too i love like anthology horror
so
john gore says i watched land of the
minotaur last night with donald
pleasance it's fun oh i don't think i've
ever seen that one actually
pistachio cookies are great to dunk in
your coffee or tea okay
did you see the new creep show episode
where some nerd had a vr machine to
insert himself into movies in horror
express yes
uh we did see that one
we actually kept up with the new creep
show stuff we reviewed some of them
but i remember that one
you remember that uh creep show episode
which one the one that was like about
the guy that inserted himself into
horror express
the peter cushing
yeah yeah yeah that was good yeah that
that was justin long right the guy that
was in tusk yeah he was in that yeah
that was a good episode i actually
really like that episode if you have
shutter
watch the new creep show most of them
were like actually really good i think
they got a new
season okay but we'll see now john
robertson did i answer your question
enough
okay unless you want to
if there's a second if there's a
follow-up question i'll take it
he was asking me if i could think of any
good peter cushing movies oh god all of
them are like journey to the center of
the earth oh that's a good one too i
like that one yeah christopher lee
wasn't in there they had [ __ ]
carolina monroe's [ __ ] hot ass that's
right i forgot about that that's right
and her boobs
chris yeah
christopher lee was not in that one but
yeah peter cushing was in there he
wasn't in that one yeah i thought i
thought he no at earth's core out of his
car edited score yeah that's not so and
but was karen on the row in that one
uh i think she was in that one yeah yeah
yeah that sort of thing uh at earth's
core out of the score that was a pretty
good movie
yeah it was him and what's that
motherfucker's name um
the guy that was in humanoids from the
dean yeah yeah i remember his naked
guy's name i'll think of it yeah it's
right on the tip of my tongue
[ __ ] help me somebody help me
help me
check out mcclure mcclure that's
deadpool clark yeah yeah doug mcgee
check out at earth's core doug mcclure
it was doug mcclure yeah and peter
cushing and carolyn monroe and well they
get into like a penis-shaped thing
that's the digging shape drilling
machine that drills deep up in your
girls under the earth
down into your core after you're [ __ ]
because you know what [ __ ] and then
they go and they find a whole [ __ ]
world leatherman that's right and
there's there's hotties and carolyn
monroe was there and yeah with her in
there and also
psychic [ __ ] pterodactyls
are in there that's right psychic
pterodactyls it sounds weird
we're not making that up it's just a i
saw that [ __ ] and the movie theater i
think kimmy saw me i think kimmy took me
to see that one
i really i i honestly have a have a soft
spot for that yeah it's i mean i think
it was like what 75 77 maybe 76 yeah
it's like mid to late 60s yeah
76 that was kind of like one of those
yeah
kimmy took me to see that i think and
then [ __ ] sinbad the sinbad movies
the sinbad and the eye of the tiger
so i saw that at the drive-in when i was
a kid yeah
yeah
but yeah man that was good yeah oh that
was really good no just one trader joe's
everybody's excited about horror express
i mean horror express that had [ __ ]
kelly cevallos in it also
briefly yeah he's kind of like a
tangential game yeah but okay
um
who's that did you see the new yeah okay
answer that favorite hammer horror
favorite hammer horror oh
that's a rough one
i don't know i'm
i like the dracula ones
but
hmm
i don't know i kind of feel like the
first dracula one is my favorite but
there's like a lot of other ones that i
was into as well [ __ ] man i even like
some of the 70s dracula ones i mean even
though they were like super cheesy
john's asking me says yeah tommy
answered it really well i'm kind of
curious
to see if you could choose your sith
name would it be i couldn't choose a
sith name because the sith had to be a
lord he had to be a fully functioning
[ __ ] sid
so i wouldn't i couldn't be that
i would be what would be called kind of
like uh
a a person with what would be
in star wars terminology would be a dark
side affinity
so no that it couldn't be a sith
so we didn't have a name
oh yeah we didn't have a name
because the sith lord would have almost
[ __ ] full
full abilities in terms of [ __ ] uh
psychokinesis
you're not giving yourself you have to
have at least psychological accolades no
if not okay no you have to have
psychokinesis first of all
uh you have to have [ __ ] dark side
affinity
you um
you have to have precognition
certain amounts of [ __ ] esp
so no yeah yeah wouldn't i wouldn't be
as if i would just have dark side
affinity
yeah
ben says darth and furious darth
infurious yeah yeah
[Laughter]
i wondered if i could like think of a
name but i just like blanked out on it i
blanked out oh well what are you gonna
do
khan says yeah i remember those sexual
pterodactyls i had totally forgotten
about sexual pterodactyls well there was
they were partly sexual yes they were
sexual i forgot they wanted to
cross-breed with women didn't they yeah
yeah or did that was eat people well
there was that whole thing where they
were kind of like
yeah look we have this cave we got a hot
chick we're gonna get there's some
pterodactyls yeah they were psyched
because actual psychosexual pterodactyls
and they were like
doing like sexual they were staring at
people giving them like psychic messages
yeah yeah
i'm not making it up it
that does happen in the movie yeah that
does that matter
well this khan has said that
yeah
that's funny
well sometimes i feel like we say some
[ __ ] that happened that actually
happened in a real movie and people
think we're like making it up yeah like
i'm just drunk and i'm just like no i
was like that actually did happen in the
movie right
there was a movie that had that you're
saying to be a sith you got to have a
raspy voice now there's a lot more to it
than that
ultimate sith would have been kind of
basically like what uh what was his name
darth plagueis the wise from what
they're describing he was evidently
killing things and then using psychic
abilities to bring these things back to
life
or to bring things up to the
brick of death and then to keep them
alive look at her look at her
okay
so that's a pretty that that that that's
a pretty hardcore skill
psych ability
and that's a very cruel that you would
have to use very cruel methods
to to practice that you have to kill a
bunch of little things
the animals
and try to bring them back or to keep
them from dying no thank you and then
you have to work your way up to humans
to understand
how to keep things from dying and how to
think how to bring things back to life
and then evidently according to the lore
how to bring something to life that had
never lived before
in other words
making kind of like a golem out of
psychic energy to bring a life form out
of it yeah just build some shadows
playing some [ __ ] out of his ass that's
a lot which evidently that's like a [ __ ]
yeah like yeah
that's what a [ __ ] anakin was and
then you take that you put that into a
woman and she gives birth
see
wait you're putting a [ __ ] monster into
my into my womb yeah
it was she said he had no father
so
that's that's a pretty so i'm giving
birth to mr hanky is what you're saying
yeah i don't know what it was i don't
know what it was i don't know that's
that's the direction but what they're
talking about is uh necromancy
that's what they're talking about
bringing things back to life
well yeah everybody knows that yeah
that's what necromancy is right
uh i learned about necromancy as a child
in the john bel-airs book the house with
a clock in his walls because it was
necromancer yeah
so i learned about that when i was like
10. yeah
where did pookie go
somebody saying i'm not sure i'm not
sure anakin was ever jedi just a laugh
or never a sith he's just a lap jedi
lapsed jedi
uh no i disagree he was just sid
um
[ __ ] he he was a jedi that turned
into a sith and then
died
he died
he died on mustafar
and then the the emperor basically
revived him and brought him back to life
kept him alive so you're my [ __ ] now
yeah he was basically kind of like a
crossing a zombie a frankenstein and a
robocop
all at once he's being kept alive by the
emperor
that's why he told luke he says i cannot
betray my master you don't understand
the [ __ ] power of the dark side he
couldn't betray his master because that
was where the source of his life force
was coming from that's why
when luke tried to [ __ ] says oh i'll
save you let's get out of here and he's
like no i don't understand it's it's
over
because once the emperor was dead
vader was gone
because he
that was what was keeping him alive well
he was like animating him yeah he was
keeping him animated yeah he was an
undead basically
i kind of like that aspect of the
mythology though yeah
i mean i feel like they didn't go into
that enough no he was undead kind of
basically yeah
he was like a vampire
a vampire essentially yeah feeding off
of a [ __ ] master
john says it's okay tom i'll be the sith
lord my sister name would be darth
calitus which means cunning in latin
okay but i would not be a sith i'd be
more of a greyjoy yeah okay
you kind of feel yeah i think i i feel
like you would probably be a sith lord
who you no i'm not evil enough you're
not you no really oh yeah according to
the lore and this would fit in with
[ __ ] other you know like i said lucas
isn't pulling this out of his ass this
is all coming from [ __ ] joseph
campbell
and
stuff inside buddhism and
nichianism
the idea of a [ __ ] sith lord is
someone who's gone beyond good and evil
so they don't there's no difference
between good and evil they're they're
higher than that you have to kill a lot
of things
okay and be unaffected by it so you have
to be a psychopath
but you can't be a garden-variety
criminal psychopath
you have to be a genius psychopath
you're talking about you're taking
somebody who's like rembrandt or [ __ ]
mozart and you're turning this person
you're elevating them outside of the
normal boundaries
of [ __ ] morality and turning them to
a basically a demiurge which is a devil
god that would that would be
that's what you're talking about in
terms of uh a [ __ ] um
uh that's what the greeks would call it
a demiurge a devil god a god like satan
so you're becoming like an edgelord that
you can create or destroy with equal
amounts it doesn't matter it's just
willpower
i will kill you or i will create you
that's what they're that's what they're
talking about
that's what the true power of the dark
side was no limits at all
it was nothing about a accruing power
the ability to create or to destroy
which that's what the yin yang symbol is
yin and yang that is also what the
swastika was
the axis upon which nature turns that's
what they're talking about which is
prior to the nazis like [ __ ] it all
up but it used to be no the nazis were
the no well no but i mean it had a
meaning private it still had the meaning
there there's there it's the same
meaning it's we are controlling [ __ ]
it doesn't matter what you think of it
it is creation and destruction change
change sorry i just thought of we are
above good and evil
we will kill you or we will help you
depending on what we want
that's exactly what they're talking
about there's no edge lordy about it
when you murder millions of people not
giving a [ __ ] because you're trying to
achieve a goal then it isn't [ __ ]
that's exactly what they were talking
about that's not edge lord
that's what it was they were bad
they have gone beyond they went beyond
it
well i'm mostly psychopath that take
that on as like a mantle being edge
lordy well when you're like that you
become the center of attention you are
the axis upon which the earth turns that
is what exactly what they're talking
about dude get over here yeah right
well if you show up into a room with a
bunch of people with an assault rifle
you start raping women and killing
people and [ __ ] smacking [ __ ] and
throwing them out the window and doing
whatever you want in that little room
you are the axis upon which the earth
turns that's what they're talking about
and then they're saying i'm gonna reward
you and punish you you're that you're a
devil god
that's that's what they're talking about
and here's the thing you're making a
moral judgment that's bad they're even
beyond that they don't care if it's bad
or or or good it's only their will
so you're saying like this is
psychopathy at its [ __ ] highest order
yeah psycho
yeah psycho a force of nature
and you know
that's what they're talking about
and that is why you should not be
allowed to like live in
regular society
they're not in society they're in nature
that's how they put it so what they've
gone is they've reversed bad they've re
i don't want to say reverted
because they didn't see it as reversion
they saw it as
going back
or returning to nature of [ __ ] prey
and predator
that they are lions and you are lambs
that the wolves are running wild because
you are prey and they are the top
echelon of the predator system
you're they are hurting you
but they like that
in the same way that a [ __ ]
wolf is devouring a rabbit
they're the wolf isn't making a moral
judgment they're just eating a rabbit
they don't care that you're a human
being
that's part of the power
that they're
they've gone beyond that that's what
they're talking about i've [ __ ]
studied it over and over again through
all the different philosophies is it
evil
yeah
yeah
but what the philosophy is saying is
that they're saying life itself is evil
to live is to be wrong
because life is about the survival of
fit of the fittest
it's kind of like
lions eating things and life feeding on
things and one thing imposing on another
so therefore you cannot exist in a state
of of fairness everything is unfair
so they're just embracing that they're
saying okay then all this is meaningless
we might as well kill all our enemies
and get as much as we can because none
of this means anything
so it's better to
live in a state of where
i run [ __ ] than to live in a state where
i'm a servant to somebody else so i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you and take what i
want it's it is very criminal very
criminal but that's the way animals are
so it's animalistic that's what we're
talking about that that's what they're
talking about
tom says jenny there's a new series
called from it's on epics
uh in a nightmarish town in middle
america that traps everyone who enters
any unwilling residents strive to stay
alive and uh search for a way out but
they're plagued by a terrifying
nocturnal creature
that sounds kind of good
um yeah everybody says that sounds good
i will check that out at some point i
don't have epics is it that's like an
add-on right for like hulu or amazon
prime or something
yeah but that does sound good i will say
though i still haven't finished archive
81 like i want to finish it i just
haven't finished it yet
so i have a hard time like finishing
series
you know
oh let's see
the nanny is free on youtube oh that's
the one with like uh betty davis yeah
that's what she was talking about
earlier
so
i don't know it's almost four hours
tina's telling me to get on breaking bad
yeah i've heard about it then everybody
says i'd love it and everything's a
great series i mean i know what happens
in it right because i haven't but i've
never like sat down and watched the
whole series which is one of the things
that i really need to do at some point i
mean
it's one of those things that
everybody's like gonna watch i was
thinking about it the other day because
i saw that i was flicking through the
[ __ ] on amazon prime it's like oh they
had mad men which i actually saw the
first
four seasons
i think and then i was like oh i gotta
finish that like i never did
because i got distracted by other things
but
i kind of feel like breaking bad is one
of those series that
you kind of have to see like because
it's part of the cultural
zeitgeist and if you haven't seen it i
don't know it's one of those things like
game of thrones you probably need to
watch that too and it's like
you know otherwise you don't like you
miss out on a lot of stuff that's it
references
so there's a real good um book
that i um
that i'm gonna go ahead and
recommend to you people who are all into
star wars and the sith and everything
and um
i read this book a long time ago the
audio book is on
youtube
okay it's three hours long
all right it's called nietzsche and the
nazis because stephen hicks is his name
and he explains the difference between
nietzsche
and what the nazis believed but also the
parallels and he explains exactly what
what what the nazis believed and it's
basically what i just told jenny
it is not what they were talking about
was not some kind of
crackpot
philosophy
it was a very real philosophy that is
very dangerous
but it's also very naturalistic but it
comes from the animal world
so i recommend listen to that he'll
explain it more in depth
um
other than that how long have we been
going jenny runs off to the restroom
but that's where that's who i was
basically quoting
and that's where my understanding of it
comes from
um and that is
basically where joseph campbell got the
ideas from star wars from the sith
um
it was a
philosophical machine gun
that'd be a good way to put it
it's a way of [ __ ] looking at things
to give yourself license to uh do
whatever you want and become a kamikaze
they were kamikazes they didn't even
expect to live when they did that [ __ ]
um
now the average person who was involved
in that ship didn't really know what was
going on but
you talking about the higher
levels of them
they knew they knew what it was
i think they also knew that they would
die
the thing is this philosophy philosophy
very tightly wound with religion
is philosophy real i'm not sure
philosophy is dangerous though
it might even be safer to believe in
nothing than to believe in a lot of that
stuff
so we've been on for four hours
yeah okay it's time to go shut down get
a breaking bad um wait a minute okay
peaky blinders you are i i've been
meaning to get to that too because
you're not the first person that has
recommended that to me so i need to get
into that also
god there's so much so i'm so like
[ __ ] behind on stuff
uh mike says my weed beer is going weed
beer okay
uh yeah so we went on for four hours
it's friday night i'm kind of hungry
okay
and
the [ __ ] that means i have to come up
with something oh yeah i got i got um
egg salad already made up yeah look at
what you should do the lighting i did i
do i do what i want
you do what you want you [ __ ] up
everything i [ __ ] up the lights
i don't know if that fixed it okay um
eggs sausage pancakes off to make
breakfast for dinner says man that
sounds good
all right we do have egg salad though so
we'll probably just have excellent
sandwiches yeah but yeah
so we look back on sunday
not entirely sure what movie we're going
to talk about
we'll probably watch something tomorrow
night and uh talk about that on sunday
but thanks everybody for dropping by
this evening and having uh you know a
good time and having some cocktails
and hanging out with us
on this friday night
we will see you guys again on
sunday afternoon when we talk about
whatever movie it is that we're gonna
talk about
so thanks everybody for dropping by
we'll see you guys on sunday afternoon
and